missing his mps this afternoon that was
after the announcement that at least 54
letters had gone in
was made by segren brady chair of the
1922 committee
the threshold of 15 percent of the
parliamentary party
seeking a vote of confidence in the
prime minister has been passed therefore
a vote of confidence will take place
within the rules of the 1922 committee
that vote will take place this evening
in the house of commons between six and
eight o'clock
and we will announce the result shortly
thereafter uh there will be arrangements
for proxy votes for any colleagues who
can't be present in person uh in
westminster and will notify colleagues
of those arrangements in the near future
scream brady there so how does the no
confidence process work
well to trigger a vote 15 of
conservative mps that's 54 of them have
to submit no confidence letters
in the vote more than half the party's
mps that's 180 need to vote against the
prime minister to remove him
if that happens there's a leadership
contest and boris johnson is barred from
running but if he wins he is safe under
current rules for a year
downing street issued a statement in
response to the news that the prime
minister would face the vote saying this
tonight is a chance to end months of
speculation and allow the government to
draw a line and move on delivering on
the people's priorities
the prime minister welcomes the
opportunity to make his case two mps and
will remind them that when they're
united and focused on the issues that
matter to voters there is no more
formidable political force
but despite downing streets bullishness
those letters of no confidence have
continued to be submitted with the mp
john penrose resigning as the prime
minister's anti-corruption champion in
light of the vote being triggered
in his resignation letter he wrote that
the only fair conclusion
to draw from the sue grey report is that
the prime minister had breached a
fundamental principle of the ministerial
code which is a clear resigning matter
sue gray report says so in terms it says
there are major problems with leadership
and he hasn't addressed that at all in
his response i think at that point it's
pretty clear that he has broken the
ministerial code in a very material way
and at that point hey i'm afraid it's
normally a resignation matter for the
minister concerned and but also clearly
i as the anti-corruptions are can't
carry on
in that role um until unless this is
addressed it feels now like a question
of when not if but we will have to wait
and see what the result is if he has a
thumping victory this evening um then
that might be different but it you know
at the moment in so far as anyone can
tell
it feels like the beginning of the end
well the former health secretary and
foreign secretary jeremy hunt has also
made his position on boris johnson's
confidence vote pretty clear in a
lengthy statement on twitter he said
anyone who believes our country is
stronger fairer and more prosperous when
led by conservatives should reflect that
the consequence of not changing will be
to hand the country to others who do not
share those values today's decision is
change or lose i will be voting he said
for change
but unsurprisingly there's been strong
support for the prime minister from some
of his cabinet members among them jacob
rees bogg dominic raab and nadine
dorries all told sky news they believe
boris johnson will comfortably survive
this evening's vote
i think remember about boris johnson is
he is a remarkably charismatic leader
people stop in their cars to get out and
say hello to him shake him by the hand
that's a charisma that nobody else in
the conservative party or indeed in the
socialist party have the difference
between boris johnson and theresa may is
that theresa may didn't go because she
won the uh no confidence vote but not by
now she went because having won that
date having secured her position she
then lost on the withdrawal agreement
three times the first time by the
biggest parliamentary majority against a
government in history and it was because
she couldn't deliver policy in the house
of commons that she had to go not
actually because of internal part
imaginations hope that mps will
overwhelmingly support him i think
i believe that they will
that will i hope as well but draw a line
behind
some of this has been speculation for
weeks now we've got a whole packed
agenda we've got a general election in
less than two years packed agenda on
leveling up on skills of course the cost
of living uh the crime and law
enforcement which is one of my areas
working with pretty patel or we can turn
inwards with what i think the public
will view as a rather self-indulgent
bout of talking to ourselves and so i
think it's important people get behind
the prime minister and i'm confident
they will i'm not worried at all in fact
i'd like to get this vote out of the way
so that we can get on focusing on the
issues that really need to be focused on
14 million people voted for the prime
minister in a general election the
biggest vote that a prime minister
conservative prime minister has had
since margaret thatcher i find it
utterly bizarre that a small number of
mps think that they can overrule that
vote
that that vote of 14 million people it's
quite something that they think they can
do that and so you know let's get this
vote done let's let's move on tomorrow
well earlier boris johnson welcomed the
estonian prime minister to downing
street but not in the normal fashion uh
karjakalas arrived earlier this
afternoon for her bilateral meeting with
the prime minister but rather than
he offering the customary greeting at
the door ms kallus had to wait for staff
to let her in
thank you for having me
we have been great allies in nato and we
are very grateful for the british troops
in estonia
the two leaders have uh now finished
their meeting discussing the war in
ukraine ms kalas thanked boris johnson
for his leadership on the world stage
against vladimir putin's invasion of
ukraine
and our deputy politician sam coats is
with me now now sam you have your ear as
far as i can tell pretty much
perpetually
to the ground the westminster ground how
do things look for boris johnson
well mark at this point here we are what
is it eight minutes into the vote of no
confidence being underway two hours to
determine boris johnson's future will
get the results at about nine o'clock
what you would expect to be happening
is potentially the rebels to be playing
down how well they think they're going
to do what's interesting tonight is
they're not quite doing that at the
moment there is some concern on the
downing street side about how they're
going to do and there is
quiet not quite optimism today i think
the rebels think that they're going to
win but there is quiet confidence that
they might surprise when it comes to the
numbers that we discover at nine o'clock
now
we don't expect uh it is an
extraordinary hurdle for boris johnson
to be outed in one go today for more
than 180 conservative mps to vote no
confidence given in part that so many of
them
are
members of the government on the payroll
in some way ministerial aids they have
jobs uh dependent on that but what i've
been hearing all day long is a
procession of people some of whom are in
the government who are on those
ministerial ranks saying no they are
going to vote in private quietly against
boris johnson today and i think that
that is the fact that there are so many
people on the government payroll now
talking about voting against boris
johnson is something i sense that danny
street were underestimating this time uh
last week so there are groups of people
that i think perhaps the people in there
uh behind us were discounting just a few
days ago that now uh they're having to
pay some attention
it's it's an incredibly high bar to uh
for boris johnson to lose but the
outcome that we could get is a very very
messy victory now one rebel leading
rebel that i bumped you to in the way uh
on the way here said that he was
expecting uh defeat but defeat by only
30 or 40 votes so we're looking at a
result of maybe 200 in favor 170 160
tory rebels against the prime minister
just stand back and imagine that 160
of the 350 odd tory mps voting against
boris johnson how does he manage to put
that all back in the box together uh try
and knit the party back together he's
not been a prime minister uh afraid of
challenges and turbulence he thrives on
that that's how he got his 80-seat
majority in 2019 uh but that sense that
uh i think that some on his own team are
now starting to or in the wider
government team are starting to question
i think is important a couple of little
straws in the wind you do have an
influential website called conservative
home paul goodman the editor writing a
piece this evening which seemed to
suggest that he that that
website that calling card website for
conservative grassroots members up and
down the country thinks that maybe boris
johnson's time uh is up uh now you have
had plenty of people coming out and
saying that they support boris johnson
uh it has been put to me that even
members of the cabinet may
say in public one thing and perhaps
doing private something else but
nevertheless uh you wouldn't be in the
cabinet if you didn't come out and
support uh boris johnson a time like
this so let's hear rishi sunak who one
time was pretended to the throne uh now
perhaps slightly hard of him but
nevertheless issuing his words of
support to boris johnson today
your former colleague the former
financial secretary to the treasury
jesse norman has written a letter today
calling on the prime minister to resign
do you agree with him
no
no
no not entirely sure what this has to do
with the statement but i disagree with
him as i i said and i support the prime
minister and but thank jesse for the job
he did when he was a minister in in the
treasury
so we've got peter bottomley i can tell
you mark was the first tory mp in the
queue to cast his ballot roger gale not
on the familiar face on many tv programs
was fourth in the queue the vote is
underway grant chat's one of the first
cabinet ministers there we get the
result at nine nine o'clock tonight okay
sam thank you very much indeed and if
boris johnson loses uh this vote a
leadership contest will then be
triggered and that would happen less
than three years since he was elected so
let's look at some of the candidates who
could stand to replace him
currently one of the front runners is
the foreign secretary liz truss
chancellor uh mentioned by sam coats
there rishi sunat was previously a
front-runner but accusations
about his wealth and the handling of
cost of living crisis and so forth has
seen his popularity
slip rather jeremy hunt the former
health secretary also is seen as a good
candidate to lead the party he ran
against boris johnson of course in the
last tory leadership vote and made it to
the final two other cabinet ministers
in the running could be the education
secretary nadim zahawi
deputy prime minister dominic raab and
also the defense secretary
is an interesting possible candidate ben
wallace and other names to keep an eye
on are the home secretary pretty patel
the secretary of state for leveling up
michael so pretty much everyone actually
the chair of the foreign affairs
committee tom tougenhart
and
the trade minister uh penny mordant
and uh joining us now is the director
and co-founder of delta poll joe twyman
who is in
central london joe thanks very much for
being with us so first of all just how
do you see this going
uh well it's it's very difficult to know
for sure in terms of the numbers i think
it's very likely that boris johnson will
get the 180 mps that he needs but the
question is how far over that threshold
will he be and what will the impact of
the victory mean i think if he gets
fewer than 227
mps it will be difficult for him because
that will mean he performs worse than
theresa may did at least in percentage
terms
and that's really a difficult story to
uh to deal with given that she was gone
within six months now of course the
context is different in this con in this
election because there is no uh obvious
rival uh waiting in the wings in the way
that boris johnson himself was last time
around the field as you just
demonstrated with your graphic is
extremely wide
for possible replacements but but i
think that 227 would be the absolute
minimum that boris johnson would want if
he can get above 275 he's probably in a
better position above 300 and he can
draw a line under things but where it
falls we just don't know
but are things different in the sense
that with theresa may it was about
policy with boris johnson it is much
more about
personality isn't it
yes i think that's uh i think that's
right to a certain extent
theresa may's inability uh to get some
of her uh some of her policies through
was at least in part attributed to her
personality but it's clear that this
time it's not about a disagreement about
about policy about brexit or anything
else this is a disagreement about the
very fundamentals of boris johnson's
personality whether the public can trust
him whether the public thinks he plays
by his own rules and whether the public
thinks he is honest those are the kind
of stories that we tell ourselves and
each other that can be so important in
determining who people vote for in the
next general election and essentially
that's the question that conservative
mps will be asking themselves tonight is
boris johnson the best person available
to win the general election next time
around and if not then who is best
placed to do that in the absence of an
obvious rival it is a big gamble to go
with somebody else but uh but many mps
made believe that that is a gamble worth
talking
and to what extent given everything
you've just said to what extent are the
polls driving this dissatisfaction
because i was having a look uh this
afternoon i mean his polling on
personal approval or
trustworthiness is pretty grim
in many ways it's the polls that are the
reason we are here the conservatives
have been lagging behind labor in the
polls now for for some time at the
national level when it comes to the the
straight voting intention question but
also perhaps more importantly when it
comes to questions of leadership boris
johnson has been very low in the polls
for some time and well below kyrstalma
and that's a bad position for any leader
to be in but particularly given the kind
of questions that are being asked about
his personality it does raise the the
big question about whether he can
recover from this position at least
sufficiently to uh to fight another
election and uh and that is the question
that mps will be asking tonight
right i mean and that is interesting is
there any polling being done or has it
been done recently on what voters think
about if he wins this
you know his ability to be able to turn
things round
well it's very difficult to uh to ask
that within a survey because because
people just are very poor at explaining
their own behavior but what we do know
historically is that when
leaders have faced leadership contests
they have generally gone on to not do
well later on now whether that would be
uh whether that be uh john major for
instance uh losing the general election
that followed his leadership contest
whether that would be margaret thatcher
who never made it to the uh the election
after having won the first round of her
leadership contest admittedly under
different rules or whether it be the
most recent example of theresa may the
conservatives have a long history of
leaders who are
fatally wounded by leadership challenges
now whether that death arrives swiftly
or over time remains to be seen but
historically it doesn't look good for
the conservatives and for boyce johnson
in particular
yeah joe thanks very much the picture
you're seeing on the right of your
screen there is
room 14 committee room where the voting
is taking place let's go live to central
lobby inside
those houses of parliament and sky's ali
fortescue and ali you've been talking to
mps what have they been telling you
yeah i've literally just come from the
committee room where people are voting
and there's a queue about 30 or so mps
outside some have
left and say they're gonna have to come
back later because there's such a long
queue it was quite fitting and that the
father of the house of peter bottomley
was first in the queue we asked him
which way he was going to vote but he
said he's always kept his views to
himself shortly um after him i think
fourth in the queue was roger gale who
knows a long time critic he called the
process of going in there and voting he
said i would be surprised by which way
he's voted he said previously that he
thinks boris johnson should go but he
described that process as very painful
and then behind him were a couple of
cabinet ministers uh alistair jack grant
shaps um so that voting is going on now
of course it's um it's going to finish
at 8 p.m we expect and then we will find
out from zagre and brady um just how
well or just how badly the prime
minister has done 180 of is of course as
we've been saying a very high bar but
the question is just how many people
will in a secret ballot vote against the
prime minister we know that he um faced
the 1922 committee earlier a
conservative party source described him
as buoyant they said he was pumped
upbeat focused
and he talked about this not being the
moment for the party to turn in on
itself but i did speak to someone who's
planning to vote against the prime
minister this evening she said she'd
been unimpressed um by his performance
at the 1922 committee she said that he
lacked passion that he was reading from
a script so um there are people that are
very angry that are trying to persuade
others to vote against the prime
minister and of course we won't have to
wait long now only a couple of hours
until we know um how boris johnson has
done in this vote of course 180 is the
magic number but i think there are a few
people that expect that he will be
immediately defeated but even so losing
a big chunk of the tory party in a vote
like this could haunt the prime minister
and could be very difficult to come from
okay ellie thank you very much indeed
this is the newshour at six live from
downing street this evening coming up
we'll have today's other news including
cutting edge the uk prepares to send
long-range missile systems to ukraine in
a bid to slow russia's advance in the
east of that country
[Music]
independent united kingdom
[Applause]
these last few years have seen some huge
stories
[Music]
and these stories have been driven by
politics by politicians the people in
power
you must stay at home and it's my job to
figure out how these decisions made by
politicians
impact all of us in our everyday lives
this is the worst thing i've ever been
through in my life people turn up here
with their child stuff in a black sack
and just say i don't want to and that is
what it is it's first class poverty is
this an example of the welfare state
failing
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
these are stories that affect us all
millions of children are now having to
catch up
some stories have changed all of our
lives because like the residents the
staff are being infected
politicians they make decisions all of
the time and it's our job to hold them
to account i wonder if you will take
this opportunity to apologize to those
families but in the end the real power
doesn't actually lie with the
politicians
the real power
lies with the people
i'm nick martin i'm the people and
politics correspondent at sky news
[Music]
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from
understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
i'm ivan bonio i'm a sailor
i spent half time of my life on the sea
we have a factory we can convert this
plastic to energy
and so after at the end we can minimize
the footprint carbon of the board
[Music]
[Music]
uh welcome back to downing street let's
catch up with some other news now and
britain is to send high-tech rocket
systems to ukraine to help the country
defend itself against russian aggression
the move has been coordinated closely
with the u.s which announced it was
sending similar weapons last week the
russian president vladimir putin had
threatened to strike new targets if
longer-range missiles are sent to keeve
sky's alastair bunkel is in dunipro
this has been done in coordination with
the americans uh it was at the request
of the ukrainians who believe they
desperately need these new missile
systems in order to strike russian
supply lines but also long-range russian
artillery deep into
russian-held ukrainian territory uh and
so
after some uh deliberating over it the
white house agreed to send these systems
and then this morning the british have
announced that they will follow suit too
the idea is it will
it won't be a game changer you know they
are precision strike they are supposed
to be very very accurate it's not
suddenly going to win the war for the
ukrainians but what they hope it will do
if they use it correctly is swinging the
momentum back in their favor
and they help push the russians back
from the positions they're in at the
moment i think they clearly have the
russians slightly rattled because over
the last week or so as rumors that these
missiles would be coming to ukraine
you've heard a few announcements from
the kremlin uh threatening to target
areas possibly even within europe itself
if these missile systems were sent here
and vladimir putin himself yesterday
said they would look at new targets
to strike if so apparently the americans
have sought a promise from the
ukrainians that they won't be used to
hit targets inside russia itself and i
think the british will have extracted
similar guarantees but what it shows to
me is the continued level of investment
that london and washington still have in
this conflict that is grinding on and on
uh just enough time for a quick look at
some of the day's other top stories and
thousands of people including school
children and teachers have been left
stranded in europe after the half term
break as travel disruption continues
easyjet cancelled 80 flights on a sunday
with almost 200
cancelled flights across all airlines
over the weekend
also people are being urged to avoid the
london underground today thousands of
members of the rmt union are striking
over a dispute about jobs and pensions
transport for london says some services
are running but the stations in central
and south london will be closed or only
open for limited periods
and a british geologist has been jailed
for 15 years for trying to smuggle
artifacts out of iraq jim fitton
collected 12 stones and shards of broken
pottery as souvenirs while on an
organized geology and archaeology
tour
under iraqi law he could have faced the
death penalty
this is the newshour at six uh live from
downing street as mps conservative mps
have been voting started voting voting
is between six and eight o'clock results
sometime around nine o'clock so stay
with us
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
we support communities to grow food in
lost and unloved spaces across the city
so our main kind of driving force is to
get people growing
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to downing street
conservative mps have begun voting on
whether or not to get rid of
their leader boris johnson historically
prime ministers who have survived a
confidence vote have had no choice but
to step down in the following months i'm
joined now by a former advisor to both
david cameron and theresa may mo hussein
thanks very much for being with us so
do you think that this could be the
beginning of the end
i think it certainly could be let's wait
and see what the results are it feels
like the prime minister way may win this
but the scale of any victory will be
important and
if it's less than the theresa may
victory which was 63 i think then i
think that will be quite damaging and
and the very fact that we're even having
a vote to no confidence in the prime
minister who less than three years ago
one uh a resounding agency majority i
think speaks volumes about how fractured
now the party is and his own authority
as well
and though he will have people like you
around him what will they have been
doing today presumably cajoling mps and
offering mps all sorts of things in
return for support
yes exactly there'll be a lot of
recounting let's say the greatest hits
of the johnson administration which we
have all heard whether it's getting
brexit done or the vaccine rollout
which are all valid things but there's a
question around how long you can dial
out on these things when people want
issues to be addressed right now and
whether it is the cost of living crisis
or whether it is uh dealing properly
with partygate so there there'll be a
lot of reminding people that the prime
minister has won uh twice in london he
won on the brexit referendum he won in
2019 there'll also be questions around
well who's next who is the obvious
successor who is the obvious
front-runner and is this the right time
with cost of living crisis that people
are experiencing and with ukraine so
these will be things that will be
used with mps just to test where they
are and see if they can fall in line but
whether they'll be successful i think we
need to uh remains to be seen because i
think the threshold for many mps has
passed and when you say something
different in private and we understand
that the prime minister when asked about
partygate said he would do it again to
conservative mps but in public you uh
somewhat apologize and you say you've
learned lessons i think that's a real
problem in terms of trust issues
and he had such a thumping victory uh in
2019 i suppose my question is how and
why has it come to this
well he did have a thumping victory in
2019 because he is a very good
campaigner and he reached part of the
countries that
no conservative leader has reached
before but there is clearly a difference
between campaigning and governing and i
think when you have a series of unforced
errors and self-inflicted wounds uh
whether it is various policy u-turns uh
that you perhaps the writing is on the
wall you march mps up the hill get them
to vote said to my only to change your
mind a bit later that erodes goodwill
if you look at partygate and the
mishandling of that where we were told
there's nothing to see here there were
no parties and we're now 126 fines later
that again uh chips away at the goodwill
people might have towards you and the
authority uh when you are trying to
govern you are trying to get laws
so i think that has all played a part i
think there's also a more fundamental
question about which way the
conservative party is going because you
hear a lot of we want to lower taxes and
you want to go back to a smaller less
interventionist state however the
government's actions don't particularly
match that rhetoric and there will be
mps on the right of the
who see a very
big government spending lots of money
intervening stealing people's lives and
they're questioning where are the
dividing lines with the labour party
what do we stand for the next election
so i think there's quite a few things
that have led to this depending on which
wing of the conservative party you're on
yes it's interesting if he does win
narrowly is he the sort of prime
minister do you think you may be able to
turn things round
i think that is uh
very very debatable because there's
always been something else it was the
local elections it was as the sukway
report it was a met police report and i
think that was now running out uh
even if he wins there is still the
specter of the parliamentary committee
hanging over the prime minister whether
he misled parliament or not mps just
want this to end they want this to go
away but he can't promise him that he
can't guarantee that and there's also
the potential for other
nations or other policy changes or
u-turns to come up which uh i think put
him still in quite a difficult position
and depending on which wing of the party
tries to please and caught the support
from you end up isolating
the other mps the other wings of the
party you may not be on the same page so
there will always be people within the
conservative party who uh have
a bone to think with the prime minister
which direction whichever direction he
goes in going forward
okay mo hussein thank you very much
indeed our deputy political editor sam
coats is with me here
i gather that um theresa may has been
casting her vote is that right boris
johnson's future is in the hands of 359
conservative mps there's a long line in
that line is theresa may wearing a black
laced bull gown
we are told she is not celebrating
instead she is preparing to go off to a
jubilee dinner but it takes story mps of
all shapes and sizes all hues and
different uh types to keep or oust a
prime minister right now look scenarios
sam because you want to talk scenarios
so you want to do four scenarios
um the first one 180 plus rebels okay so
what we're going to see tonight is 359
mps uh voting let's look at uh what
different sizes of the number of rebels
might mean 180 or more and he's gone
he's out two years ago two and a half
years ago boris johnson was the biggest
electoral asset that the conservative
party's seen since margaret thatcher and
he will have been ousted from power
still some uncertainty about exactly
when uh he'd leave office would he
resign handed his resignation to the
queen uh straight away maybe hand over
power to dominic rob or would he just
wait staying in office until a
leadership contest that he can't take
part in uh decides who his successor is
but 180 or more and boris johnson is out
of the door so that's a fairly clean-cut
result
but the most messy results the second
scenario i'm going to give you is if
there is
133 or more rebels 133 up to 180 if
that's the margin of rebels then that's
significant that's a very narrow win for
the prime minister why 133 that's
because that's the proportion
of rebels that there were when theresa
may faced a vote of no confidence in
other words if he's more than 133 every
opponent of boris johnson will be
allowed to go around and say boris
johnson did worse than theresa may look
she had to fall on her sword it's only a
matter of time uh until he does now a
hundred rebels or more well that starts
to be the rate if it's 100 or less that
starts fewer then that starts to be uh
the moment where danny street might be
able to keep uh a lid on this uh i think
that 100 is the number uh that uh down
history are hoping that their ceiling is
but uh that even if it's under 100 the
challenges aren't all out the way you've
got those two bar elections later this
month you've still got a standard
inquiry look into whether or not boris
johnson light so all of those different
scenarios i'm going to give you one
final number and that's 40 because for
all of these large numbers if there are
40 rebels who are willing to vote
against boris johnson then in future
whenever there's a tight vote and those
rebels vote in legislation with the
opposition then boris johnson risks
losing and so whatever the number
tonight it's going to be damaging
because it shows he might not have the
command the commons really going forward
that you need uh to be a successful
prime minister interesting and just look
30 seconds
i'm just interested in the timing why
have the rebels chosen to go for this
now
i think that uh there hasn't been a very
well coordinated plot there's been a
different bits of the party reacting the
only thing that was coordinated was an
attempt to make sure this didn't happen
during the jubilee period with some
letters held back until the right the
end of festivities last night it would
have been more tactically sensible if
you want to ask boris johnson to do it
after the by-elections i think that is a
sign that this isn't this plot doesn't
have one central coordinator but is lots
of different wings of the conservative
party deciding that they think time is
up for boris johnson sam it's really
interesting we'll have another chat in a
moment or two thanks very much indeed
this is the newshour at six live from
downing street coming up tonight's vote
will determine the fate of boris
johnson's leadership
but has the damage already been done
[Music]
please just make their first move and
they're bothering firing together
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
there are hundreds of these turbines but
thousands more across gansu
that's what's left of the north tunnel
where the north koreans exploded five
nuclear warheads
[Music]
and this is a show of strength at a time
when china is more fragile than it has
been at any time in recent years
shrapnel from that explosion you can see
it littered along all the way we take
you to the heart of the stories that
shape our world
the train station the airport they're
both closed we're not sure about the
roads we've seen reports that they are
being blocked by police so we're going
to try and find a way out
after five days stranded here this is
deliverance we help you understand the
world with us
tom cheshire sky news beijing
[Music]
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
you either live and recover
or you die
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from
understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
i'm ivan bonio i'm a sailor
i spent
half time of my life on the on the sea
we have a factory who can convert this
plastic to energy
and so after at the end we can minimize
the footprint carbon of the board
welcome back to downing street we hope
in a minute to speak to professor vernon
bogdanor a professor of government at
king's college we're just waiting for
him to get uh connected deputy political
editor sam coats is still with me sam i
mean i mean let's just talk about how we
got here this thumping
win in 2019
and uh delivery of brexit and now he's
in this mess
there's a fashionable phrase about boris
johnson which is that the prime minister
is the greased piglet of british
politics always able to escape from the
scrapes of whatever
he's got himself into and there have
been a lot of things whether it's
wallpaper and downing street holidays in
busted the stuff around owen patterson
the mp who was found guilty of breaking
standards breaking sleaze laws last last
year and then of course infamously
partygate but what mps today have been
very clear with to me is it isn't that
he simply escapes from the net each time
because he is some kind of houdini of
modern politics but each one of those
things has salami sliced his reputation
with both the public and with mps and it
is this gradual accumulation of things
that have resulted in today's vote okay
sam thank you very much and uh we are
now joined by the professor of
government at king's college london and
uh incidentally one of uh david
cameron's former professors vernon
bogdanor thank you for uh being with us
and i just want to
just get a historical perspective on
this because votes of confidence uh do
not work well for leaders um
let's start with margaret thatcher she
faced a vote of no confidence didn't she
absolutely right
the point of a vote of no confidence is
to clear the air
to discover either that the leader has
uh support still has support from the
parliamentary party or that he or she
doesn't now
margaret thatcher didn't have that
support or rather she didn't have enough
on the rules of the time to continue and
she went now in a way that did help the
conservative party because
i believe that unless they've changed
their leader unless john major had
become leader they would not have won
the 1992 election which they won
unexpectedly in another way it didn't
clear the air because it opened the way
for a civil war in the conservative
party which continued throughout the
1990s and this is what some people fear
about boris johnson that if they voted
him out there would be a civil war in
the conservative party that it would
reopen ideological conflicts perhaps
between the three marketeers and the
interventionists which boris johnson's
rather shall we say colorful character
ahead from view
another occasion on which it did clear
the air was in opposition when ian
duncan smith was narrowly defeated as
leader of the opposition in 2003 so
it's mixed but the likelihood it seems
to me tonight obviously no one can tell
that there will be a large number of mps
who are opposed to boris johnson
it may not be a majority but it'll be
quite a large number and if that's so
the leadership election will not clear
the air it will just as it were kick the
damage down the road
yeah and just talk to me too about john
major and then theresa may because
broadly speaking the picture seems to be
that these
votes whatever the result do not work
out well for prime ministers
john major in 1995 actually
as it were called a vote of confidence
in himself he resigned as conservative
party leader but not as prime minister
and challenged anyone to oppose him now
in the end john redwood did
and john major won comfortably in terms
of votes
but given that he thought most of the
payroll vote that his ministers and
parliamentary sectors had voted for him
a large number of backbenchers were
actually opposed to him now the
opposition candidate was john redwood
who's still in in the house of commons
but he appeared to many people as rather
eccentric and many thought that if
a more promising candidate such as john
paul
sorry michael portillo or michael
hesseltein had stood they would have
defeated john major or at least pressed
him so hard he would have had to resign
now john major lost a general election
two years later my suspicion is that
anyone would have lost the 1997 election
to tony blair
for nearly
18 years by 1997.
so that didn't work now theresa may in
in 2018
she won a vote fairly convincingly by
nearly two to one she got 63 percent
of the conservative back benches
supporting her but seven months later
she was out
so
if you have a large number of people
hostile to even if it's not a majority
it's very difficult to survive
yes it's interesting so professor tell
me why you think it is that leaders find
it so difficult to recover from these
votes of confidence is it just a
gradual
erosion of authority
well we're talking about the
conservative party which is the most
successful party in british electoral
politics arguably the most successful
political party in the democratic world
and the conservative party sees itself
as having a governing vocation so
they're quite ruthless towards their
leaders if it appears that a leader is
not going to help them win the next
general election that leader will be
turfed out and this is why we see so
many eruptions in the conservative party
in my opinion
is there a chance that boris johnson is
the sort of
prime minister the sort of leader who
maybe could buck the trend
well he's often been underestimated in
the past
he won two elections as mayor of london
and london afterwards a left-wing city
doesn't normally elect conservatives
and then he won
in a sense a referendum he was a leading
figure in the brexit campaign
and he achieved a convincing majority in
2019 and then politically of course he
broke the brexit deadlock
he got brexit done to use the phrase he
he really in one way removed it from the
political agenda it's now guested his
argument brexit on the whole er i think
so he's got great achievements to his
credit now the question conservative mps
have to
answer is has that magic faded
has partygate permanently affected his
political and electoral reputation or
can he recover from it that's a very
difficult question to answer because who
can foresee the future
absolutely and just on the rules of all
this
if he wins
is it right that he doesn't face another
uh challenge for
a year or
is it very easy to change the rules what
do you think would happen
two former chairs of the 1922 committee
that is the conservative backbench
committee
stated at the time of theresa may's vote
of confidence
that they could change the rules that
conservative mps could change the rules
the rules were there to suit the
convenience of conservative mps and if
they found
that a leader having won a vote had
nevertheless lost authority well before
the end of another year they might well
try to change the rules the important
point to note is this i think that the
leader of the conservative party
particularly when he or she's prime
minister has enormous power and
authority that he or she leads only as
long as the mps follow and when the mps
cease to follow the leader ceases to
lead that is a lesson that leaders such
as edward heath margaret thatcher and
theresa may have all discovered
okay well professor very interesting
thank you very much indeed
uh our deputy political editor sam coats
is still with me a couple of minutes or
so sam uh until the top of the hour so
give us an idea of what you expect we
will see tonight we're approaching the
halfway mark where ballots just over
another hour to go where ballots can be
cast we haven't heard that boris johnson
has voted yet number of members of the
cabinet uh have however some suggestions
uh that dominique robbed your prime
minister actually edged his way to the
front of the queue uh michael gove there
cueing and looking jolly uh and sanchez
javid uh smiling when he thinks that
people are looking at him now i think
that this is a pivotal point there was
always going to be some kind of showdown
moment after the whole partygate affair
it was delayed of course because of
ukraine
but what is striking what is
extraordinary what is interesting about
this evening is the numbers it's always
the numbers on nights like this now uh
you have uh
clearly to get more than 180
conservative mps uh to vote no
confidence in boris johnson to whisk him
out the door
and quite whether we'll get to that very
very high hurdle is is unclear but today
the sky news tally compiled by my
colleague tom larkin
puts the number of tory mps publicly
declaring that they are going to vote no
confidence in boris johnson or raising
questions about boris johnson at over
50. so you've already got a number big
enough to overturn his majority if there
was a contentious issue and they wanted
to vote against him so boris johnson is
already in serious trouble and just the
question is how high is that number uh
going to go and whether or not if boris
johnson survives as prime minister he
can then piece uh his leadership back
together again potentially with a series
of controversial announcements maybe to
do with brexit and northern ireland
maybe to do with reforming this civil
service there are lots of tricks that he
can pull but the question is will a
narrow win be enough for him tonight or
will that just continue those questions
because we've got another decision point
that in about three weeks time when the
uh voters in the south west uh and in
wakefield go to the polls uh at those
two by-elections so tonight might not
settle everything 30 seconds left uh but
the interesting thing is that you talk
about public declarations
i mean it is a secret vote isn't it we
just don't know but it's not just the
people who have spoken more than a
hundred more than 130 tory mps haven't
told anybody what way they're even
leaning that is why tonight is so
exciting and nobody can be certain about
the result okay sam uh thank you very
much indeed keep your ear to the ground
as the evening progresses thank you very
much for being with us uh this hour that
was the newshour at uh six thanks very
much for watching coming up
stay with us for a special program on
tonight's confidence vote in the prime
minister that programme coming up with
sophie ridge
[Music]
[Music]
organisms
[Music]
we support communities to grow food in
lost and unloved spaces across the city
so our main kind of driving force is to
get people growing
[Music]
[Music]
it's seven o'clock this is a sky news
special programme on tonight's
confidence vote in the prime minister
coming up conservative mps are voting
right now on the future of boris johnson
as he fights for his political survival
and this is the room where mps are
casting their votes mr johnson needs a
simple majority to survive lose and he
must step down
well voting goes on until 8 pm we're
going to be bringing you all the latest
as concept mps finally show their cards
he's got every big call right they think
a different leader would be the best way
forward i don't agree with them nobody
has had forced me to come out to support
an exceptional good forward-looking
prime minister it's pretty clear that he
has broken the ministerial code i
wouldn't put any money on this at all
either way
[Music]
hello good evening conservative mps are
deciding the future of the prime
minister with the confidence vote in
boris johnson taking place right now
well mr johnson needs a simple majority
of 108 tmps to vote in his favor in
order to cling onto power lose and he'll
be ousted well throughout this special
program i'll be joined by no less than
three cabinet ministers backing their
boss as well as some of the rebels
hoping to topple their own leader
our political editor beth rigby has the
story of the day so far
after a weekend which saw the nation
come together to celebrate one leader
today another watching his followers
split apart the uneasy jubilee truce
between the pm and his party over and a
vote of confidence called the threshold
of 15 to the parliamentary party seeking
a vote of confidence in the prime
minister has been passed therefore a
vote of confidence will take place
within the rules of the 1922 committee
that vote will take place this evening
in the house of commons
the pm told yesterday the rebellion
against him had cleared its fast hurdle
with at least 54 of his own backbenchers
deciding it's time for him to go his
supporters dispatched to insist he must
stay i'm hoping we get through this vote
tonight and we can get on and he's a
he's a festival he's a dead man walking
thank you very much he's a dead man he's
a strong leader he will get the get the
big calls right and thank you very much
for all your time
and a warning perhaps a threat that
replacing 1pm with another will bring
even more pain the history of new
leaders should that happen which i think
is very unlikely is that they need an
election to assure their position gordon
brown didn't and it was a big mistake
theresa may promised she wouldn't and
then did boris johnson had one within a
few months of taking over so
conservative mps should think very
carefully
do they want a general election
but this rebellion's been building for
months bringing in different sides of
the tory party from all intakes please
of cabinet loyalists doing little to
change the minds of those out of
patience this letter from a long-term
ally and former treasury minister set in
the tone of the day jesse norman
attacking the pm for presiding over a
culture of casual law breaking and
calling his response to the grey report
grotesque
he was soon followed by this man boris
johnson's anti-corruptions are resigning
after concluding his boss broke the
ministerial code it feels now like a
question of when not if but we will have
to wait and see what the result is if he
has a thumping victory this evening
then that might be different but it
at the moment in so far as anyone can
tell
it feels like the beginning of the end
and that is what others think too this
long-term rival and possible leadership
contender jeremy hunt breaking cover
today to urge colleagues to vote for
change the party infighting becoming
ever more public and ugly i don't want
to talk about personalities but i'm
afraid sometimes it just has to be said
there are individuals who do believe
that they who don't like brexit who are
remainers who have been able to whip up
a number of mps in the party and i'm
afraid that's just not acceptable
what mr johnson's enemies and allies can
agree on is that the pm is unlikely to
lose this vote but facing such an acute
leadership crisis boris johnson nowhere
to be seen in public today leaving the
estonian prime minister alone on the
doorstep of number 10 as the british
prime minister hid inside his political
woes disrupting expected protocols
in just two and a half years since that
historic election victory boris johnson
has gone from being the most successful
conservative vote winner since margaret
thatcher to lose in the support of
dozens of his own mps who have triggered
a vote of confidence in his leadership
it is an astonishing fall from grace
from all powerful to deeply damaged from
untouchable to deeply tarnished and this
isn't about policy divisions this is his
detractors say about personal failings
of the prime minister and even if he
wins the vote tonight which allies are
confident that he will
the tory civil war has now been
unleashed and this prime minister risks
surviving but not being in any position
to lead the pm in here tonight trying to
convince mps to stick with him telling
them the best is yet to come but these
past few months have been the worst of
times for so many in his party and
anything borrow resounding johnson
victory tonight can't draw a line under
that beth rigby sky news westminster
well this is the room in which
conservative mps are casting their vote
right now we can't bring you inside the
room unfortunately that glass window is
the best that we have but of course we
will bring you the result of what is
happening in there just as soon as we
have it
a bit of breaking news to bring you now
because john lamont mp has tweeted to
say uh tonight i voted against the prime
minister in the vote of confidence he
goes on to say i've also resigned as pps
to liz truss at the foreign office so
that's a kind of junior
role a bad carrier role if you like but
again someone resigning from their post
and confirming that they have voted
against the prime minister
he said that he's consulted widely with
his constituents in the scottish borders
he's received thousands of emails about
the prime minister's performance over
the last few weeks and months and saying
as many have been saying over the last
few days and weeks that the events in
downing street during the lockdown were
unacceptable
so another mp there confirming he's
voted against the prime minister and
resigned as a parliamentary private
secretary so how does a no confidence
process work let's have a quick look now
shall we so to trigger a vote 15 of
conservative mps that's 54 had to submit
no confidence letters that of course has
happened and then in the vote more than
half of the party's mps that's 180 need
to vote against the prime minister in
order to remove him if that happens
there's then a leadership contest and
boris johnson is barred from running but
if he wins in theory he's safe for a
year
well let's talk now to our political
editor uh beth rugby uh who is here uh
with us and beth let's talk numbers
shall we 180 is the magic number that's
the threshold for which it's very clear
what happens he either stays or goes
but it's a bit more complicated than
that i guess there's no
yeah it's more complicated than that in
the there's 160 to 170 mps on the
government payroll and that means that
the prime minister has given them a job
and really they need to be loyal to him
or as john lamont has just done you have
to stand down he's a junior uh pps
to it to a minister so it's a very
junior role but he's resigned because he
doesn't want to support the prime
minister so you would expect that uh
those people would back the pm but of
course the difficulty with all of this
is that it's a secret ballot
so people might say publicly that
they're backing the prime minister and
when they're in that ballot room uh
marking their paper they might take a
different view so it's hard to know
where the numbers will fall because
there's this big chunk of mps that you
would expect to be loyal but you don't
know how that's going to play out even
supportive tweets i guess and then b
exactly this and this is this is
and this is the difficulty i'd say the
other thing about the numbers when it
comes to this vote is there is no one
obvious who is organizing in the way
that jacob reese morgan steve baker lead
and brexiteers organized mps against
theresa may now steve baker and i
remember covering that story had a
really good handle on the numbers with
this it's been much more amorphous mps
from different wings of the party bit
steve baker or steve hammond
you know brexiteer versus a remainer be
it from you know the david davis intake
to some of the new intake like aaron
bell
uh there's been uh it's it's across
different factions of the party it's
across different intakes and it's quite
amorphous so it's quite difficult to do
the counting also um obviously if you
get to 180 uh mp's voting no confidence
that it's clear boris johnson has to go
but what happens if he's bruised yeah
well they don't hit 118. and this is
exactly kind of where people are talking
about tonight which is what would be a
good result for boris johnson would be a
resounding victory in that he keeps the
rebellion down to single to double
digits so you can get 100 under 100.
when you get into 100 110 120 130 140
that type of territory that's really
damaging for him it was interesting this
morning at jacob rees-mogg and sorry the
reason over a hundred is damaging is
because that's over half of the
parliamentary party that at the back
benches not on the payroll majority
of your back benches and jacob rees-mogg
today and dean doris weinstein both of
them were really clear they said he just
has to win by one vote that's a very
different story from what jacob
rees-mogg was saying when he was
orchestrating against theresa may when
theresa may uh lost the confidence of
117 of her mps that at the time was 37
percent of the parliamentary party uh
jacob reese said that was a terrible
result and she should resign and i think
the question i have tonight is there's
an expectation on both sides that the
prime minister will survive this not
least because you get 15 of mps to
trigger but you have to get over 50 in
like 12 hours to actually cascade
for him to lose
but is he going to end up in office but
not in power so he's so damaged by it
that he can't recover and part of that
would be about the numbers part of that
is how he handles it afterwards will he
make a statement will he sound uh
contrite but
because i think it's quite an
interesting point as well because it
does feel about with partygate that
perhaps was that exactly you pushed a
few people over there pushed a few
people over the line but when you look
at past records be it margaret thatcher
to john major to theresa may
pm's having to face confidence votes end
up wounded walking wounded uh dead men
walking or dead women walking as as
george osborne once said of theresa may
and that's the question that he survives
but he can't lead that he's in office
but he's not in power and he can't
recover one senior mp said to me tonight
look you know when you've lost when over
70 percent of the public think you are
lying that's quite a difficult place to
come back from yeah it really is uh beth
thank you very much for your analysis
we'll have lots more from beth uh as the
uh program rolls on it's gonna be pretty
busy throughout a few couple of hours i
would imagine now as we said mps are
voting right now so let's go live to the
place where it's all happening the house
is parliament we can talk now to our
deputy political editor sam coats who is
in central lobby
sam what are you picking up from the
conversations you're having with mps
there
well we're expecting boris johnson to
vote
shortly sanji javid recently voted
michael gove has been in the queue
peter bottomley was the first mp heading
the queue
and theresa may in a bull gown black
lace affair i'm told she's going to a
jubilee party later rather than making a
statement about boris johnson although
she hasn't held back on her criticism in
the comments about boris johnson we just
don't know what the outcome of tonight's
vote is going to be it was always quite
likely that there was going to be some
kind of showdown some kind of vote after
the partygate affair even though it
dragged on for months even though events
in ukraine
rather put the kind of showdown between
boris johnson and his party on hold for
some weeks nevertheless this moment has
been a long time coming mp's in favor of
boris johnson leaving the office of
prime minister saying look it hasn't
been the case that he is a greased
piglet who can escape from any uh of the
controversies that we've seen over
recent months instead each one has done
damage damage to their standing damage
to their standing in the eyes of voters
and so there's an accumulation of issues
i think that have led uh to today's vote
uh some numbers safely worth bearing in
mind of course 180 mps is what it's
going to take to oust boris johnson but
that margin of 133 to 180 that would
mean boris johnson wins tonight but does
worse than theresa may did in january
2019 she of course fell on her sword
some months after a vote of no
confidence with that result if people
can go around saying that boris johnson
did worse than theresa may innovator of
no confidence that uh will be damaging
number ten will be hoping to keep the
numbers to under a hundred the sky
spreadsheet has 54 tory mps either
either publicly declared against boris
johnson or have come out with criticism
but one other number uh worth bearing in
mind sophie is 40. it takes just 40 mps
conservative mps to switch slides sides
and vote with the opposition and that's
boris johnson's majority gone so if he's
planning big bold things to try and get
his government back on track
then they clearly look like there are
numbers uh who are able uh perhaps not
winning yet because they don't know what
the plans are but are able to disrupt
those the the atmosphere here in
parliament is uncertain uh i just spoke
into one of those uh uh minister uh mps
that's resigned their government post
they said that uh people are cautious
many wanting to hide what they're doing
right now there are tellers sitting
outside the 1922 committee room where
tory mps are voting to try and nail down
exactly what's going on inside that
secret ballot you won't ever be able to
do that you don't even know whether the
cabinet members who came out publicly
back boris johnson this morning are
going to end up
voting
voting uh for or against uh boris
johnson but what we do know is that the
number is over a hundred particularly if
the number is over 133
uh then in that case boris johnson is in
for a very torrid time even if he might
be able to declare victory later tonight
at 133 another number for us to look out
for sam thank you very much for your
analysis uh we'll be coming back to you
throughout the programme well let's now
bring in the conservative mp for north
annette roger gale who's been pretty
critical of the prime minister i think
it'd be fair to say uh for some time
you've also submitted a letter of no
confidence have you voted yes absolutely
i was the fourth person to vote wow very
keen to get in the queue then by all uh
counts it was a long queue and how have
you voted i mean we no surprise to
people but just explain how you voted i
voted
no confidence and why why is that
because i think um sam actually is on
the nail on the head it's an
accumulation of factors it's not just
partygate
um i put my lettering in fact as i think
you know sophie after the
barnard castle affair
because i thought the prime minister's
judgment was faulty i thought so then i
think so now and i think all the events
in between
have just
strengthened my view that we need
another prime minister
i guess supporters of boris johnson
would say look he's just come from an
enormous election victory there's nobody
else who has got that kind of proven
record of winning elections recently for
the conservative party why on earth
would you want to switch horses now
well quite simply because he's not the
right person for the job
and i've heard this argument over and
over again there isn't another person
well actually we're spoiled for choice
there are at least half a dozen probably
more people who might well throw their
hats into the ring well anyone in
particular that you think is well i'm
not i know i don't want to give you one
name i quite prepared to give you half a
dozen go on them um well okay dominic
raab has been the deputy prime minister
he's acted as prime minister i'm not
certain that he would get it but he
might want to go for it liz trust has
made her ambition
i think very plain indeed she would like
to be prime minister
ben wallace
is probably responsible for the real
work that's been done in ukraine and for
ukraine very safe pair of hands and a
former soldier um he might want to go
for it
penny mordant who is trade minister at
the moment uh was secretary of state for
defence briefly it could possibly the
dark horse tom tugnat
the chairman of the foreign affairs
selection i mean do you want me to go on
i mean there is a and they're all good
people
so
we have got a choice and
if we get to the leadership election
then those people will play their cards
and then we'll decide who we want to put
forward to the party membership allies
of boris johnson say this is people who
want to rerun the old brexit arguments
again it's people who have got beef with
the prime minister if you like um
long-standing issues with the prime
minister that are just kind of coming to
the fall now and they're just using the
recent events this is absolute rubbish
um this is something that the prime
minister has brought on himself
brexit divided the party that is
absolutely true
it's curious isn't it that the party is
now divided not over policy
but over the character of the prime
minister
that's quite extraordinary it's
character you think rather than anything
else yes
not policy but character no i mean i'm a
conservative i got elected on a
conservative manifesto
i won't take my baton ball away i'm not
going to go on strike and not vote i
shall vote for conservative policies
that i believe for the right policies
and that will mean most of them i mean i
vote for all of them because nobody
agrees with everything but
i shall certainly vote
with my party
but i don't have faith in this prime
minister
let's talk numbers
um because it does feel beth was just
saying earlier in the program it's quite
hard to get a grip on exactly where the
numbers are at because it does feel
quite unorganized i guess like people
from different wings of the party it
doesn't feel like one big faction that
is organizing in the way that we've seen
in previous votes of no confidence
where do you expect the numbers to end
up
well
as i said to beth rigby this morning and
she's been saying i think all day the
consecutive parliamentary party is the
most disingenuous electorate in the
world
um they will tell you one thing and then
do something else so i don't think
anybody really knows we know that 54
letters have gone in minimum
because that's what was necessary but
after that it's anybody's guess what
happens if the 118 number the absolute
the
simple majority number isn't hit
but the prime minister is still bruised
he gets more than 100 of his own mps
more than 120 same voting against him
he's not going to resign as he he won't
resign
theresa may honorably resigned
and margaret thatcher honorably resigned
because they felt that they lost the
confidence of the party
mr johnson will not resign and that's
going to place us all in a very tricky
position indeed because patently you
can't
un-vote your no-confidence
um i have no confidence in the prime
minister i've said that very publicly i
can't un-say that so what then happens
then if he doesn't resign
and yet he has had this bruising vote
what happens well i fear we have a
divided party
and divided parties don't win elections
but this
sophie is not about for me winning the
election
this is about the governance of the
united kingdom that's what really
matters that does that will also affect
the governance of the united kingdom
won't if he can't control his own party
yes and it's going to be very very
difficult indeed but somehow we have to
work through this
we'll have to see what happens tonight
and then the next steps will have to be
considered do you think that you could
change the rules of the 1922 committee
so that
you can re-challenge the prime minister
in less than a year i'm not expecting
this but i understand yes there is a
facility to change the rules that can be
done and maybe that has to be done and
further downstream there may be people
enough a lot of people maybe
who feel that you know they made the
wrong decision now and they want to make
it
change it later but let's see what
happens tonight and then
worry about that tomorrow okay thank you
very much for coming on the program uh
good to talk and as you said uh as roger
g was saying that it does feel like a
difficult uh result to really get a grip
on where the numbers are heading but not
too long until we find out
and the results of course are going to
dominate tomorrow's newspapers i'm sure
that will happen we'll have our extended
press preview and news review from 10 30
this evening with tonight's news and
tomorrow's headlines joining us live
from downing street will be the daily
mirrors political editor pippa creer and
the times as home affairs editor matt
bathen
you are watching our special program on
the confidence vote coming up we'll have
plenty more ahead of the confidence vote
in boris johnson we are going to be back
live in parliament
[Music]
independent united kingdom
[Applause]
these last few years have seen some huge
stories
[Music]
and these stories have been driven by
politics by politicians the people in
power
you must stay at home and it's my job to
figure out how these decisions made by
politicians
impact all of us in our everyday lives
this is the worst thing i've ever been
through in my life people turn up here
with their child's stuff in a black sack
and just say i don't want to and that is
what it is it's first class poverty
is this an example of the welfare state
failing
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
these are stories that affect us all
millions of children are now having to
catch up
some stories have changed all of our
lives because like the residents the
staff are being infected
politicians they make decisions all of
the time and it's our job to hold them
to account i wonder if you will take
this opportunity to apologize to those
families but in the end the real power
doesn't actually lie with the
politicians
the real power
lies with the people
i'm nick martin i'm the people and
politics correspondent at sky news
[Music]
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from
understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
hello welcome back we've got a bit more
now on the breaking news we brought you
just a few moments ago the conservative
mp john lamont has resigned as liz
truster's parliamentary private
secretary in order to vote against boris
johnson in tonight's confidence vote now
it hasn't taken long for our deputy
political editor sam coats to manage to
track him down he's i think you managed
to call him already haven't you sam what
um let's what do you have to say
uh well john joins me now so let's ask
him first of all uh john you've just
announced you've resigned uh as a
ministerial aide to liz trust moments
before voting in the election about uh
to see whether the conservative
parliamentary party has confidence uh in
boris johnson why did you do that so it
was a very tough um decision over the
course of um today i spent many hours
and reflecting on
what the decision i i was going to take
and i consulted with my constituents and
the scottish borders to find out what
they would um like me to do and how they
felt about the prime minister's
performance and ultimately decided that
i couldn't give the prime minister my um
support and that was a really tough um
decision and i also felt that having
voted against the prime minister i had
to give up my parliamentary aids
position with um liz trust the foreign
secretary which is a job that i love
doing and very much respect and liz was
very sad to leave the foreign office
that's how you did it can you tell us
why you did it what is it
that means that you don't think boris
johnson is fit to continue to be prime
minister of this country so i've become
increasingly concerned about
the activities have been widely reported
that have been going on in downey street
and very concerned about the culture
in um downey street and i was becoming
increasingly alarmed i suppose that a
lot of the good work that the government
is doing both in scotland and across the
united kingdom was being was being lost
by this distraction of constantly having
to explain um all the events that have
been going on during lockdown in uh in
downey street during the lockdown so um
i i feel the government needs renewed
focus and perhaps the new leader might
provide that and you think that it is
better to throw the dice have the gamble
that a messy leadership contest followed
by a new leader pressing reset on the
party maybe two and a half years at max
out from a general election provides
more stability than boris johnson
staying in post so that's the decision i
mean the colleagues 54 or so colleagues
who present the letters and they made
that i didn't put a letter in there they
have decided that now is the moment to
to have this this ballot and the rules
and requires to have this ballot
battlefield
you want a messy leadership contest that
would follow from calling for the
business that is the mechanism to to
bring about the the change that i now
think we need
at the top and i mean what is it that
you fear if boris johnson stays in post
well as i was saying my worry is that
the government's priorities and the good
work that the government is doing is now
being diluted and lost because of this
constant discussion and largely by the
media but also by our constituents about
the ongoing events or the events that
happened during lockdown in in downey
street i don't think that is good for
the government's overall and policy
objectives now you have stood down from
your job as a ministerial aide because
you've taken this decision about boris
johnson this evening
perhaps some would say that's an
honorable course of action to take do
you think there are other members of the
government who'll be voting against
boris johnson this evening but are
staying inside the tent
it's a matter for
my colleagues in in government to to
either disclose um how they voted or
just keep it secret i know many will not
be disclosing how how they have voted i
felt it was the honest thing um to do i
had asked my constituents for their
views they had given me their views in
large numbers and i felt at the end of
that process
i should reflect that and getting tell
them how i uploaded them just before we
go one last thing did you watch the
prime minister in the 1922 committee
earlier this evening
i was in the house of commons i didn't i
wasn't actually able to attend because
there are reports that he told tory mps
when asked pressed about the sugree
report that he'd do it again defending
his actions how do you feel about that
well i certainly was not at any parties
during um lockdown and i think it's
important we followed the rules of of
the land i certainly wouldn't encourage
lawbreaking
thank you very much indeed one less
figure in government ministerial aid to
liz trust resigns tonight uh about two
and a half hours two hours until we find
out what that result uh is for that will
determine boris johnson's future
thank you uh very much uh sam sam there
uh talking to the latest person to
confirm they voted against boris johnson
in this confidence vote well let's recap
shall we some of today's other main
headlines because there was a
high-profile intervention earlier when
the senior former cabinet minister
jeremy hunt said this on twitter
conservative mps know in our hearts
we're not giving the british people the
leadership they deserve and we're set to
lose the next general election
he then went on to say this today's
decision is change or lose
i will be voting for change so pretty
clear there of jeremy hunt confirming he
is going to be voting against boris
johnson
in the confidence vote it's significant
because really he is the first
high-profile potential challenger to
boris johnson to reveal his hand
then there was this from another
government minister this is from a
former government minister i should say
this is from jessie norman
he said
that the su grey reports
showed that mr johnson presided over a
culture of casual law breaking at 10
downing street going on to say to
describe yourself as vindicated by the
report is grotesque
so pretty much saying there justin
norman that it was partly boris
johnson's response to the subway report
that pushed him over the line it was a
pretty eviscerating uh letter i have to
say from jesse norman also criticizing
the prime minister's policies too well
let's bring back in our political editor
shall we beth
it's difficult isn't it because i guess
we're starting to get a sense of why as
you said earlier if prime ministers face
these confidence votes they they end up
being very damaged by it because it's
getting ugly isn't it yeah it's really
interesting as well just um in terms of
uh what happened uh with jeremy hunt and
dean doris which we'll come onto in a
sec because uh this morning number 10
put out um a lines to take note uh and
in it they talk about um trying to avoid
a a civil war a blue one blue civil war
will be vicious and tear the party apart
it says uh that it said we should reject
chaos and division and back the prime
minister
and it goes on about distracting
decisive destructive civil war but the
civil war is it's on it's out there and
it has got really ugly today um as you
were saying um jeremy hunt uh put out a
series of tweets saying that it was time
to change leadership uh he is an obvious
contender long-term rival he was in the
final two boris johnson then uh sacked
him from cabinet and and he never came
back
and dean doris who is the cultural
secretary and a key ally of uh johnson
then put out a series of tweets
really attacking really unpleasantly
attacking jeremy hunt one rebel said to
me um that nadine dorrie's was one of
the best things that could have happened
to jerry hunt today because of what she
said i think we've got yeah because you
you you
jeremy hunt today has come out himself
i'm surprised you haven't mentioned this
has come out today himself and said that
he is time for change i think what he
means is it's time for him
and you know i don't want to talk about
individual personalities but what i
would say is that you can't say
repeatedly that you're not going to
challenge the prime minister while as a
war in ukraine and on the day russia
fires rockets into kiev decide that it
is time for a change of leader
wow getting pretty messy
it is and actually what was interesting
was i spoke to another rebel after that
conversation and they just said part of
how the prime minister handles this vote
is about how it works afterwards and
nadine dorries and jacob rees-mogg two
key allies saying one vote to win is
enough that doesn't really resolve the
bigger problem that we've been talking
about which is how mortally wounded is
he can he bring the party back together
and quite frankly to have
a sit-in cabinet minister uh going out
in that way to publicly criticize so
personally a colleague i mean she said
in a tweet um your pandemic preparation
during six years as health sector was
found wanting inadequate your duplicity
right now in destabilizing the partying
country to serve your own personal
ambition she said if you've been leader
you'd have handed the keys of number 10
to corbyn you've been wrong about almost
everything you are wrong again now
that's a sitting cabinet minister so on
the one hand number 10 are saying let's
not have a civil war and then one person
is actually stoking that or you know a
cabinet minister spoke in that and i
think there's disquiet amongst mps today
because they felt is the prime minister
giving nadine dorie's uh permission to
do this or is she freelancing either
which way it does nothing to try and
heal these very open deepening and raw
divisions within the party at the moment
yeah well i'm sure we're going to hear a
bit more of that from them it kind of
feels like there may be some people
keeping their powder dry until the
result is known but i just wonder what
will happen afterwards beth thank you
very much as always for your analysis
well conservative mps as we know are
deciding the future of the prime
minister right now with a confidence
vote in boris johnson taking place we
can now hear from another of boris
johnson's cabinet ministers at kit malt
house who joins us now thank you very
much for being with us have you voted
yet and have you voted
i have voted yes voted for the prime
minister within five minutes of the poll
opening
i guess we just have to take your word
for it don't we this is the thing it's a
secret ballot um it could be that you
know people like yourselves are going
out there defending boris johnson and
yet actually in private you're pulling
across
beside
the
to say that you have got no confidence
the prime minister so how can we be so
sure that you know you do have faith in
him
well that's uh a dreadful count column
later level at me i've been working with
the prime minister closely since 2008 we
were successful at city hall been
successful fighting crime uh uh over the
last two or three uh years uh we weren't
allowed to take our phones in if we did
i would have taken a photograph to prove
it to you but i definitely voted for him
as i'm sure a majority of the members of
parliament my colleagues will have done
so uh we'll find out in about half an
hour you say that you're sure that a
majority of the parliamentary party uh
will have voted in favor of boris
johnson's uh leadership um what is your
sense about the mood among conservative
mps right now
so obviously the mood is is challenging
people find it dismaying to go through
this kind of process it's it's less than
ideal but the vast majority of
colleagues are coming out strongly in
support of the prime minister he got a
lot of support in the 1922
you know the the numbers declaring
themselves on social media although we
shouldn't take that necessarily as read
um as uh sort of legit um if you like
our are strong i think momentum is is
going in our direction and he performs
strongly at the 22 with a really good
message about the momentum that he wants
to begin to give to the government once
we've been through this process and i
think that's landed well with colleagues
you accept that the prime minister and
the cabinet may need to show a bit more
humility conservative mps have been
really bruised by the last few months
haven't they the sue grey report that
the police investigation the revelations
about what was going on in downing
street have hugely upset so many of
their constituents and they feel many
feel that the prime minister hasn't
shown enough humility about that so far
he got booed at the jubilee the polling
is showing that voters simply don't
trust him do you understand some of the
frustration that many of your colleagues
feel
of course we do and of course the prime
minister does he's apologized profusely
many times for the mistakes that were
made at downing streets
much of that anger
other than saying sorry
other than saying sorry what has he
really apologized
for well he's apologized for the
mistakes that were made at downing
street he's shown um if you like action
on that apology by changing the
structure at downing street bringing in
new people to to run the show there very
significantly just a couple of months
ago just just to come back on that just
to come back on that apologize just to
come back on that because
i have heard that quite a few times to
say that the prime minister's completely
changed downing street and i just wonder
how true that is i mean he's still in
his job isn't he as prime minister the
head of the civil service is still in
their job there has been movement in
downing street but it's not necessarily
the people who've been fined who've been
uh moved is it it feels that it's
actually just
this churn and downing street that was
going to take place ever anyway and the
two most senior people haven't taken
responsibility
well i think that's unfair i mean he's
obviously tried to change the structure
in downing street with a new permanent
secretary to bring a greater sense of
rigor to the operation of that
building he
took the
responsibility and apologized for the
mistakes that were made
um
under the kind of previous management if
you like and he's changed that very
significantly he obviously participated
in a number of events which he's also
apologized for the cake one obviously uh
was a fine and he's apologized for that
as well but you know he he has shown a
big commitment now to stepping forward
away from this particular situation
giving momentum to the party and a
really compelling agenda which i think
is attracting members tonight and with
20 minutes or so to go in the vote i
know that more and more of them will be
going through uh to vote for him so that
we can get on with this big bold agenda
that was laid out frankly only a couple
of years ago in a general election she
resoundingly won with a massive majority
and that's what we really want to get on
with okay 180 is obviously the magic
number the threshold by which he's
either safe in his job at all he has to
go
but if he
ends up being bruised by the process if
there's for example more than 120 more
than 130 conceptual mps voting no
confidence do you think there's any
chance of the prime minister resigning
well look i just don't think that's
going to happen i think there's going to
be a resounding win and the prime
minister is very well versed i've known
him a long time at healing organizations
that have been through this kind of
process right he was a uh as mayor he
helped to heal the capital once it had
been through the riots he healed the
conservative party after that leadership
election that he participated in with
jeremy hunt i'm sure he can do the the
same again and while i think he's going
to have a thumping victory in an hour
and a half or so
obviously our job will need to be done
for everybody to accept that and bind
the party back together again as i say
as we pursue this really compelling
agenda for the next couple of years now
you say you think there'll be a thumping
victory to find a thumping victory
well i think he's going to win the vast
majority it's hard to speculate on what
the numbers are are going to be but i
think you'll find it's a satisfactory
margin so in the single in the double
figure zone rather than the uh over 100
i do think he's going to do very well
yes i think he's going to come out with
with better numbers than is being
forecast in the media you've got to
remember a lot of flak is thrown up in
the air to try and create momentum in a
particular direction particularly by
opponents but actually i think when the
vast majority of mps are in that ballot
booth and they're thinking about the
decision and the agenda that they want
to see in the next couple of years as we
move towards the general election they
absolutely will recognize that this is
the man who can give momentum uh to the
party in this post-covet atmosphere as
he did twice in london and as he did in
2019 to lead us to a thumping victory in
2024 or or
no 2024 december um is the date and are
you concerned about the damage this
might do to the conservator party uh in
parliament you know we've seen the spat
haven't we between jeremy hunt and
nadine dory's these things do get quite
ugly pretty fast and how difficult do
you think it will be to draw everyone
together afterwards
yeah look emotions run very high they
they do um at these kind of incidents
and i was uh there for when theresa may
was challenged that emotions ran very
high then but once it's done and the
ball is launched people generally come
back together again because in the end
we are a family the conservative party
we are a coalition of people who come
together to pursue a political cause in
which we all believe and once these
decisions are taken my experience is
generally people come back together
again and focus on the real challenge
which is winning the next election and
just finally um according to the rules
uh if you win a vote of no confidence
then you can't be challenged for a year
but there's been lots of speculation
that the rules themselves can actually
be changed um
if boris johnson wins the vote of no
confidence should that be it for a year
or do you think that it would be
acceptable for him to face another one
no those are the rules those the rules
under which we uh play the game if you
like under witch's pursuit it's a bit
like saying should we change the rules
of football halfway through the final no
i mean he's gonna win thumpingly he's
then uh protected for 12 months but
during those 12 months i know he's going
to put the country on on the front foot
in terms of building more houses you
know fighting crime getting the economy
firing all cylinders helping people with
the cost of living all those things that
we need to put together in a really
compelling cocktail to take forward to
that election 2024. okay he's going to
win thumpingly that is the verdict of
kitten mulhouse thank you very much for
coming on the program today thank you
thanks a lot
uh kate matthaus they're uh talking to
us just ahead of the close of the vote
20 minutes left uh for conservative mps
to
put their cross uh in the box we'll
bring in the result as soon as we have
it after that well there's lots more to
come as we head towards the uh result of
course which is expected around nine
o'clock we have got lots more online as
well so just scan the qr code that
should be on your screen right now and
then you can read all of the latest news
and analysis that's in our politics hub
so plenty of content for you there
now tonight's vote would have seemed
unthinkable two and a half years ago
when boris johnson's conservatives won
the general election with an 80-seat
majority our deputy political editor sam
coats has been looking at how on earth
we got to this point a warning that his
report does contain flashing images
right from the start
a conservative winner like no other in
four decades
[Applause]
an unconventional path which took him to
the heart of the establishment proving
doubters wrong with an 80-seat majority
tory mps were told time and again to
trust him through the turbulence
holidays and wallpaper but who paid for
what upending the rules for an mp found
guilty of sleaze parties in downing
street and the denials that followed
but dealing with brexit the pandemic the
cost of living crisis and war in ukraine
never allowed a moment for politics as
normal
all the time gradually the public were
changing their mind
now mp's today putting his survival to a
vote
veterans of past story leadership
challenges clear whatever the result
does trouble ahead what we have seen
today is a classic example of a party
where its fractures become very very
open
between the members of parliament as
they're looking for their own particular
constituency so it's a big deal and it
can't be underestimated and boris
johnson whichever way this evening's
vote comes out is going to be damaged
there's no two ways about it
all this barely three years on from the
last attempt to ouster pm the
parliamentary party
does have confidence
[Applause]
theresa may survived on the day but was
gone within six months
history suggests vote like today's
rarely settled matters
john major was never the same again and
mark thatcher fell on her sword uh and
theresa may uh was
uh faithfully wounded i think sam if he
gets a if the vote against him is less
than a hundred uh even better if it's
less than
75 he will be
in a strong position
a messy victory for boris johnson might
leave things unresolved tonight but
would the outcome of two key bar
elections later this month change minds
could boris johnson be judged to have
lied on partygate or is this
conservative party determined to place
its faith in the man who delivered a
landslide barely three years ago sam
coates sky news westminster
it could be a quite extraordinary
turnaround if it happens but of course
as kit mahal says some are predicting
he's going to win thumpingly not long
until we find out you're watching sky
news coming up we're going to be having
continuing coverage of the no confidence
votes in the prime minister the cross
bench peer baroness wecroft will be
joining us live
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
please just make their first move and
they're bothering firing again
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
there are hundreds of these turbines but
thousands more across gansu
that's what's left of the north tunnel
uh where the north koreans exploded five
nuclear warheads
[Music]
and this is a show of strength at a time
when china is more fragile than it has
been at any time in recent years
[Music]
shrapnel from that explosion you can see
it littered along all the way we take
you to the heart of the stories that
shape our world
the train station the airport they're
both closed we're not sure about the
roads we've seen reports that they are
being blocked by police so we're going
to try and find a way out of wuhan
and after five days stranded here this
is deliverance we help you understand
the world with us
tom cheshire sky news beijing
[Music]
we're enormous explosion it's just come
down
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
you either live and recover
or you die
welcome back we can get a bit more on
events at westminster that of course
dominating uh this evening the vote of
no confidence in the prime minister that
is taking place as we speak well there's
around just over 10 minutes left of
voting to go
as mps uh let everyone know whether or
not they have confidence in boris
johnson the prime minister we've got
somebody else
though who has nailed their colours to
the mast and that is the mp dehenna
davidson she's put out a statement on
facebook to say
many of you or her constituents have
understandably asked how i intended to
vote in this evening's confidence ballot
in the prime minister though it is a
secret ballot it feels right to share
with you how i voted she goes on to say
this is not a decision i took lightly i
listened carefully to all sides and
particularly to the many constituents
who contacted me sharing their thoughts
and experiences weighing it all up i
voted against the prime minister tonight
i hope that whatever the result we
politicians can now fully focus on the
things we were elected to do for you now
this is significant because dehena
davidson confirming there that she's
voted against the prime minister
tonight she won at her seat uh bishop
auckland at the 2019 general election uh
it is exactly the kind of red wall uh
constituency uh that helped boost the
prime minister in that election back in
2019 and it's really one of his big
sales to
wavering mps that he's an election
winner
and yet of course here you have uh
somebody who is the epitome if you like
it of the kind of red wall seats that he
won in that election to hannah davidson
saying that she's voted against him and
it's particularly she says because she's
listened to the constituents who
contacted her sharing their thoughts and
experiences so perhaps a sign of trouble
ahead for the prime minister will he get
the thumping majority that multihouse is
predicting or could it be more of a
bruising night in store just over an
hour until we find out
well the timing of the vote today came
with something as a surprise as many
expected conservative mps to potentially
wait until after the two key
by-elections that are coming up in
tibetan and hometown as well as
wakefield as well our people in politics
correspondent nick martin has been
speaking to voters in wakefield to find
out what they make of the political
turmoil in westminster
in the next few weeks this cathedral
city in west yorkshire will vote for a
new mp
and the result could tell us a lot about
how people feel about the prime minister
and his government
cities like wakefield which were labor
for so long turned tori in the last
general election and that helped to
secure victory for boris johnson but now
a recent poll suggests that labour are
20 points ahead here and if that's true
then the conservatives could be heading
for a crushing defeat in this
by-election
it's been a bruising time for boris
johnson and the lockdown parties and
subsequent fines seem to hit a nerve
with some voters the things that he's
done put us in lockdown then have his
own party
he's just gone against his own word so
it's disgusting really why was he
ignoring the restrictions why was he
ignoring the rules is it the partying
that's really
got you upset it's not helped his case
does it it's not helped it no
if it came to a general election a vote
now
would you be happy for him to continue
as a prime minister
i've got an option
you've got no option no option
the tory win here in 2019 was remarkable
labor after all had held this seat since
the 1930s
the question is whether after everything
that's happened have they got enough
support to win again it just comes
across as a bumbling a bit idiotic at
times and
end the day he's going to live and down
his sword and he made the rules and he's
decided to break him
so you you had faith in him you had
faith him in the beginning you were
willing to vote for him but it's the
party thing is it that's that's dented
that faith
i would definitely say the party that if
he can't keep his own rules he can't be
trusted and trust is the main thing that
you need as these kids growing up you
want the best for their for their future
and given that you know how he's led
over the past few years it's not been
great
support for politicians can flourish and
wither in the blink of an eye annetta
ford is a florist in the city and she's
also a loyal conservative
what he's done since brexit covet
and ukrainian war
um
that is that is the main thing so i'm
looking on the bigger picture not just a
glass of wine and i've i got that
confidence i have to say
yeah
so you believe that
going forward he should remain prime
minister because he's getting more right
than wrong
well yeah in a nutshell yeah
a defeat in wakefield would pile even
more pressure on the prime minister at a
time when confidence in his leadership
is being tested to the limits nick
martin sky news wakefield
yeah those two really tricky uh
by-elections still coming up of course
for the prime minister or whatever
happens uh tonight for the conservative
party well let's speak now to our
political correspondent ali er fortescue
shall we because you have been right
where all the action is going on and you
have been
outside the room where mps are voting
now this is on committee corridors and
it's kind of like deep in the in the
rabbit warren of westminster so what's
been going on so it's quite a sort of
thin corridor and there were when i was
there about 30 or so mps outside
queueing some of them got a bit bored of
waiting so they were like well i'm going
to go and come back and we saw the first
in the queue were saying the father
house as peter bottomley he wouldn't
tell us which way he was voting then
there were a few cabinet ministers
people like grant schapps roger gail who
you spoke to yeah he said he was fourth
in the queue i think he was quite proud
of being exactly i think yeah i mean he
has been one of the very first critics
of the prime minister but he came out
saying um that it was very painful i
said how was that and he said it was
really painful and i think there are a
lot of tories that have really had to
think deep and hard about this because
they are worried that this is going to
be damaging for the conservative party
we've just seen in the last few moments
tehena davidson she's put out a message
on facebook saying that she's been
thinking about this this has pained her
um but she's decided to vote against and
it's quite interesting to henry i
thought because she of course represents
british auckland like the first
conceptual mp to represent that see uh
in many ways the the epitome of the
success of boris johnson
in the 2019 election yeah and yet she's
now saying she doesn't have confidence
in him yeah and i think
what i have heard from a lot of mps i
think there's obviously genuine ango
partygate there's some people that
annoyed about um when full tanks and
things like that but i think what is
most concerning to a lot of people is
that he's lost that touch with the
electorate that they've been home over
recess they've spoken to constituents
and they really feel like
he that confidence that he inspired the
way that he managed to win over people
in the red wall
perhaps he's lost that and i think you
know the local elections labour actually
didn't do particularly well in the red
walls so some conservatives took some
comfort i think from that but the
predictions are that we know we've got
these by-elections coming up one in
wakefield and one in tibetan home but in
two very different parts of the country
and the expectation for many of the
polls is that they could lose both of
those seats and i think there are people
that think that he is losing his touch
with elected electorate and they've been
speaking to people that have been going
home you know people saying that people
have been coming up to them at jubilee
parties and that is why they're voting
against the prime minister i really
don't know what where it's going to go
though i feel i think it's actually
really difficult to predict yeah um it
felt like um you know you're much
younger than me ellie but you know i
kind of feel like i'm veteran of these
protesters by now and often there's
someone organizing like a steve baker
type who's got a pretty good eye on the
numbers the spreadsheets are going
around whereas this time round it almost
feels as if it's accidentally gone over
the line of letters to trigger it and
it's like herding cats no one really
knows where it's going yeah and i think
i don't think anyone really expects that
they will win i think that's quite
unlikely um and i was speaking to some
rebels this morning that sounded pretty
sort of unhappy with the way things were
going i think they thought that some
people on the fence would go that way
but hadn't um but then you hear people
that are more optimistic i think what is
interesting as you say is the government
minister people like nadine doris saying
this is a big organized movement it
really doesn't feel like that in there
um it feels like you know you've got
brexiteers 2019 intake uh veteran people
like david davis you've got theresa may
allies um
it doesn't feel organized and i think
therefore it's quite unpredictable um
worth saying on theresa may we just saw
her going in in a ball gown before um
yeah which was amazing she went in to
vote in a lovely black ball game she
must have a dinner event or something
yeah she said she's got a jubilee speech
that she's rushing off to make
a bit of a color i would love to have a
penny for theresa may's thoughts i would
absolutely love to know what is going
through theresa may's mine right now
boris johnson of course are all fallen
in her side during her leadership ali
thank you very much for uh the
update you are watching our sky news
special programme on the confidence vote
in boris johnson coming up we're going
to have continuing coverage of the
crucial evening for the prime minister
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's eight o'clock this is a sky news
special program on tonight's confidence
vote in the prime minister coming up
conservative mps have just finished
voting on the future of boris johnson as
he fights for his political survival
this is the room where mps have been
casting their votes over the last two
hours he needs a simple majority to
survive lose and he must step down
well we are expecting the result at 9 00
pm so just an hour's time we'll bring
you all the latest as we build up to a
decisive moment for british politics
he's got every big call right they think
a different leader would be the best way
forward i don't agree with them nobody
has had forced me to come out to support
an exceptional good forward-looking
prime minister it's pretty clear that he
has broken the ministerial code i
wouldn't put any money on this at all
either way
[Music]
good evening the votes have been cast
the future of the prime minister is
about to be decided after conservative
mps have just finished casting their
ballots in a no-confidence vote in boris
johnson he needs a simple majority of
180 conservative mps to vote in his
favor in order to cling onto power lose
and he will be ousted well in the next
hour we're going to be hearing from
cabinet ministers and also some of those
rebels looking to topple their leader
plus we will of course bring you the
result as soon as we have it that should
be around 9 00 p.m
we of course been hearing from many
conservative mps who are starting to
give us a bit of an indication about how
they have voted the latest uh dehenna
davidson who really is a poster girl for
the red wall the first ever conservative
mp to hold the seat of bishop auckland
she has said she's voting against boris
johnson but of course we just heard from
kit malt house the government minister
saying he believes that the prime
minister is going to get a thumping
victory not long until we find out first
though our political editor beth rugby
has the story of the day so far
after a weekend which saw the nation
come together to celebrate one leader
today another watching his followers
split apart the uneasy jubilee truce
between the pm and his party over and a
vote of confidence called the threshold
of 15 of the parliamentary party seeking
a vote of confidence in the prime
minister has been passed therefore a
vote of confidence will take place
the pm told yesterday the rebellion
against him had cleared its fast hurdle
with at least 54 of his own backbenchers
deciding it's time for him to go his
supporters dispatched to insist he must
stay i'm hoping we get through this vote
tonight and we can get on and he's a
he's a festival he's a dead man walking
thank you very much he's a dead man he's
a strong leader he will get the get the
big calls right and thank you very much
for all your time
and a warning perhaps a threat that
replacing 1pm with another will bring
even more pain the history of new
leaders should that happen which i think
is very unlikely is that they need an
election to assure that position gordon
brown didn't and it was a big mistake
theresa may promised she wouldn't and
then did boris johnson had one within a
few months of taking over so
conservative mps should think very
carefully
do they want a general election
but this rebellion's been building for
months bringing in different sides of
the tory party from all intakes please
of cabinet loyalists doing little to
change the minds of those out of
patience this letter from a long-term
ally and former treasury minister set in
the tone of the day jesse norman
attacking the pm for presiding over a
culture of casual law breaking and
calling his response to the grey report
grotesque
he was soon followed by this man boris
johnson's anti-corruptions are resigning
after concluding his boss broke the
ministerial code is he done whichever
way now
i i fear that that is probably the case
i think it's over and i fee it feels now
like a question of when not if
at the moment in so far as anyone can
tell
it feels like the beginning of the end
and that is what others think too this
long-term rival and possible leadership
contender jeremy hunt breaking cover
today to urge colleagues to vote for
change the party infighting becoming
ever more public and ugly i don't want
to talk about personalities but i'm
afraid sometimes it just has to be said
there are individuals who do believe
that they who don't like brexit who are
remainers who have been able to whip up
a number of mps in the party and i'm
afraid that's just not acceptable
what mr johnson's enemies and allies can
agree on is that the pm is unlikely to
lose this vote but facing such an acute
leadership crisis boris johnson nowhere
to be seen in public today leaving the
estonian prime minister alone on the
doorstep of number 10 as the british
prime minister hid inside his political
woes disrupting expected protocols
in just two and a half years since that
historic election victory boris johnson
has gone from being the most successful
conservative vote winner since margaret
thatcher to losing the support of dozens
of his own mps who have triggered a vote
of confidence in his leadership it is an
astonishing fall from grace from all
powerful to deeply damaged from
untouchable to deeply tarnished and this
isn't about policy divisions this is his
detractor's say about personal failings
of the prime minister and even if he
wins the vote tonight which allies are
confident that he will
the tory civil war has now been
unleashed and this prime minister risks
surviving but not being in any position
to lead
the pm in here tonight trying to
convince mps to stick with him telling
them the best is yet to come but these
past few months have been the worst of
times for so many in his party and
anything borrow resounding johnson
victory tonight can't draw a line under
that beth rigby's sky news westminster
uh beth right be there well let's go
live now to the houses of parliament so
whether all the action is happening and
we can talk to our deputy political
editor sam coats who's in central lobby
uh i think you've got a guest with you
have you sam who was there
that's right sophie so the voting has
finished uh the votes are being counted
we've got about an hour to go uh to find
out the results all the work's been
being done upstairs from where uh i am
right at the moment um and boris
johnson's future continues to lie in the
balance as we wait for graham brady to
stand up uh just after nine o'clock and
deliver uh the results of the vote of no
confidence i'm going to talk to a guest
in just a moment but before we do just
to run you through uh to give you some
sense of where the mood is here in
parliament uh of course we need 180 mps
or more uh to vote no confidence if
boris johnson is going to be ousted as
prime minister so he will be hoping that
that doesn't happen if more than 133
conservative mps vote against boris
johnson uh then then opponents of boris
johnson will be able to say that he did
worse than theresa may who also faced a
vote of no confidence downing street on
the other hand will wouldn't be wanting
to keep the number of vote of rebels to
below 100. so we will find out the
answer in about an hour uh but joining
me is uh essentially a boris johnson
loyalist stuart anderson uh
wolverhampton mp how did you vote and
why well i voted for boris johnson
i gave my support to boris johnson in
2019 as did the bulk of the british
people and the people of wolverhampton
southwest elected me with boris johnson
as a prime minister i don't believe it's
for us to change the prime minister it's
the british people who elected him and i
stand behind him and support him
constitutionally it is for you that's
the way our system works nps vote for a
leader that leader of the largest party
is the prime minister it very much is
your decision who runs your party are
you saying you just didn't think it was
right to vote or you're just voting you
do continue to back boris johnson as
leader so i did vote
i think it is right that we vote now to
make that decision but i don't think we
should have made the decision to call
the voter of confidence in the first
place i believe we should have
stood behind boris johnson and continued
to deliver for the british people
there's a lot of important things we
need to be focusing on and talking about
rather than internally wondering who
should lead our party it's not the right
time to be doing this and it's not for
the good of the country more than 50 of
your colleagues have come out publicly
and said that they don't back boris
johnson some would say that some said
that they will vote against him in the
voting conference others clearly just
very unhappy what's wrong with them in
their in your why do you think they've
ended up in the space
that they have it's up to people how
they vote and i'm not going to call out
any colleagues they've got a choice to
make what i would say
is we need to get this vote over the
line tonight we need to see the result
and we will do it at nine o'clock until
then nobody knows the outcome of what
that's going to be and i call in on my
colleagues to unite for the good of the
country we need to get behind
the pm and move forward that's um
hopefully that he wins which i want him
to tonight what do you think a good
result would look like less than 100 mps
voting against him
no well i don't want anybody to vote
against him but people are going to do
that i'm not going to speculate on
numbers i want to see
the prime minister stay as prime
minister to lead this country and then
move forward and i want to see unity
within our party if we're divided we
will not win anything or do anything of
great substance you will be happy
provided you get a win whatever the
numbers in that case so 179 178
conservative mp rebels you would be
content with that result and believe
that he should continue to go on uh as
prime minister yeah you only have to win
by one but i want a stronger majority to
win by that and then as i say i want to
see unity moving forward would you find
it disappointing if you did worse than
theresa may when she had a vote of no
confidence um if you uh if you if you
use the same percentage 133 colleagues
voting against her if you did worse than
that but stayed in office would you be
comfortable with him continuing i'm
actually not comfortable with the whole
today i think we've made a massive
mistake getting to this place and we
need to move forward from this today is
a real sad day to be a conservative we
are not shining in glory and there is no
winner in this
boris johnson addressed the 1922
committee mps i'm sure you were in the
room uh amongst them um
there were reports that he said that uh
if he had to he'd do it all again when
it came to the sugro report can you just
explain a lot of people have heard that
explain what he was talking about that's
a complete misrepresentation of what he
said he said that he was in uh in the
cabinet room where he was presented with
a cake and he did not see he was doing
anything wrong there uh hindsight more
things have come out but the prime
minister has come to the house
extensively and apologized i believe in
forgiveness he's made uh made mistakes
he's said sorry we need to forgive move
forward changes have been made and we
need to focus on delivering for the
british people finally does a bit of you
worry that your colleagues won't do that
either the 50-plus who've come out
publicly already or however many votes
against him tonight that actually what
we're seeing is the starting gun on tory
civil war
i hope that's not the case we don't win
the british people don't win if that is
the case stuart anderson thank you very
much indeed and there you go can boris
johnson put this back in the box if he
wins by what margin will he win we'll
know in an hour
and that margin could be at all
important uh sam thank you very much for
your analysis well i'm joined now in the
studio by alex stafford who is the
conservative
mp for rother valley um you voted how
did you vote i voted to support the
prime minister i think he's the right
man for the job i think gets the big
calls right i think we need to get
unified actually get on with what we
like to do are you governing the country
running the country
and this naval gazing is not helping
anyone now you're the mp for rother
valley so you were exactly the kind of
mp the conservative mp who won seats for
you know the first time taking them off
labor uh in the red wall the poster boys
if you like for for boris johnson's
election winning capabilities do you
still think he's as popular in suits
like yours i think the prime minister is
like no other politician we've had for
generations in this country he reaches
those demographics there's people who
wouldn't normally vote i remember the
local elections last year people say i'm
not going to vote conservative but i
will vote for boris's party again and
again and again that's they said the
local elections last year
in may where we went from zero
conservative councillors and rather than
20 the biggest increase of any area
and we keep hearing that still people
people know that boris cuts through in a
way no other politician has done or will
do afterwards it's interesting listening
to you and then also hearing from people
like dahina davidson the mp for bishop
auckland who has said on facebook today
that she has voted against the prime
minister now she's the first ever
conservative mp for that seat winning it
at the 2019 election too
and it's clear that you know some mps
are hearing different things from what
you're saying that they're saying that
their constituents are writing to them
that they are saying how disappointed
they are in the prime minister in
particular
over party game you're not getting that
of course i'm getting people who have
emailed in who are not a happy situation
none of us have the situation the prime
minister himself said he's not happy the
situation which is why he was fined and
has apologized i think he recognized
that was a mistake what happened but we
want to move on and look forward i think
ultimately it comes down to
what actually matters what are the big
calls and i believe those big decisions
those that matter to everyday lives
whether it's brexit the vaccine rollout
what's going on in ukraine those are
things we should judge the prime
minister on whether or not he had a
slice of cake or whether or not
kierstahl had a bottle of beer or
nicolas version with face masks those
are the things that really matter to
every day's life the cost of living the
energy price what's going on ukraine
covid those are things that actually
make the decisions and the prime
minister gets it right time and time
again on those big matters let's talk
about uh numbers
what's your sense of how it's going to
go it's not long is it 45 minutes
well i don't think anyone's gonna know i
think we're hearing names today or
people who say they are going to support
the prime minister who are now not going
to and vice versa where people i know
people colleagues who were not going to
support the prime minister until today
so i think it'd be quite you know
premature to guess the numbers that
we're going to hear about in 45 minutes
but i do think the prime minister for my
senses he'll win and he'll win
convincingly amongst colleagues so what
does convincing mean i i know i spoke to
kit mart house earlier he said that he
thinks he's going to have a thumping
victory for the prime minister you say
he's going to win convincingly
what does that mean i think he will do
better than let's say theresa may in a
similar situation when it comes to a
percentage of them
number but i think he'll do better than
that clearly against you that he's
clearly wildly popular even when you go
out and about do you say he's wildly
popular
and i i appreciate the 2019 election
result was landslide but is he wildly
popular if you look at the polling it's
not saying that is it it's saying that
it amongst pretty much all voters
they're losing faith in the prime
minister at the local elections he got
absolutely thumped not not nothing like
mine not in south yorkshire not in
places in the north in the midlands are
though hell very steady yeah in the
south of the country to the lib dems in
scotland in wales and actually labour
did make up ground in the red wall as
well but not not in my pathway well in
south yorkshire uh we we still
maintained we still won rather valley
from labour looking at the box accounts
and stuff and clearly there are there
are some sort of concerns people around
but generally those new voters i'm going
to realize the prime minister reached
out to those people who've never voted
tori before people have never voted
before he's still popular there he
people still understand him he still
cuts through he still gets that message
across okay um how concerned are you
about the damage this is doing right now
to the conservative party brand oh i
think this uh no comments vote is a
complete sort of navel gazing and the
last thing it's distraction it's trying
to drag this situation on rather than
focusing on what actually matters which
things like cost of living uh what's
going on in ukraine we are having this
self-reflection internally and i'm
frankly disappointed in colleagues
taking us this situation we should just
be getting on with the george and when
the general election comes whenever it
is but probably in two years we will
then be judged as a package about
whether we have delivered people we've
leveled up got inflation under control
rather than just these sort of moments
of madness frankly which some colleagues
are doing i mean you we saw some like
nadine dory's for example her
frustration with jeremy hunt so the
potential leadership challenger comes
spilling over do you sort of share some
of those frustrations
i i haven't seen the actual content of
what she said but i have also frustrated
with colleagues we should be united
together and show the public that we are
delivering for what actually matters
what really matters i must say well i
was out and about at the uh the jubilee
celebrations in my constituency people
did talk about politics but it was about
the cost of living it's about the rising
energy price but that's also problematic
for you isn't it though because people
think you haven't done enough and that's
why we need to do more and we are a huge
package already and we still got two
more years to deliver rather than
spending time having votes in parliament
about whether or not someone had a slice
of cake and whether the apology was not
or is it sufficient we should be
actually continuing to focus on what
matters and showing actually we do have
this plan to get things sorted okay
thank you uh very much indeed for coming
on the program today
alex stafford there and people rother
valley you are watching our special
program on tonight's confidence vote in
the prime minister coming up we'll have
plenty more as we count down to the
result of the vote that's expected at
around 9pm
[Music]
independent united kingdom
[Applause]
these last few years have seen some huge
stories
[Music]
and these stories have been driven by
politics by politicians the people in
power
you must stay at home and it's my job to
figure out how these decisions made by
politicians
impact all of us in our everyday lives
this is the worst thing i've ever been
through in my life people turn up here
with their child's stuff in a black sack
and just say i don't want to and that is
what it is it's first-class poverty is
this an example of the welfare state
failing
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
these are stories that affect us all
millions of children are now having to
catch up
some stories have changed all of our
lives because like the residents the
staff are being infected
politicians they make decisions all of
the time and it's our job to hold them
to account i wonder if you will take
this opportunity to apologize to those
families but in the end the real power
doesn't actually lie with the
politicians
the real power
lies with the people
i'm nick martin i'm the people and
politics correspondent
at sky news
[Music]
i'm ivan bonio i'm a sailor
i spent
half time of my life on the on the sea
we have a factory we can convert this
plastic to energy
and so after at the end we can minimize
the footprint carbon of the board
welcome back well tonight's fate would
have seemed almost unthinkable two and a
half years ago when boris johnson's
conservatives won the general election
with an 80-seat majority our deputy
political editor sam coats has been
looking at how we got to this point a
warning that his report does contain
flashing images from the start
a conservative winner like no other in
four decades
an unconventional path which took him to
the heart of the establishment proving
doubters wrong with an 80-seat majority
tory mps were told time and again to
trust him through the turbulence
holidays and wallpaper but who paid for
what upending the rules for an mp found
guilty of sleaze parties in downing
street and the denials that followed
but dealing with brexit the pandemic the
cost of living crisis and war in ukraine
never allowed a moment for politics as
normal
all the time gradually the public were
changing their mind
now mp is today putting his survival to
a vote
veterans of past story leadership
challenges clear whatever the result
does trouble ahead what we have seen
today is a classic example of a party
where its fractures become very very
open
between the members of parliament as
they're looking for their own particular
constituency so it's a big deal and it
can't be underestimated and boris
johnson whichever way this evening's
vote comes out is going to be damaged
there's no two ways about it
all this barely three years on from the
last attempt to oust the pm the
parliamentary party
does have confidence
[Applause]
theresa may survived on the day but was
gone within six months
history suggests vote like today's
rarely settled matters
john major was never the same again and
mark thatcher fell on her sword uh and
theresa may uh was
uh faithfully wounded
i think sam if he gets a if the vote
against him is less than a hundred
uh even better if it's less than
75
he will be
in a strong position
a messy victory for boris johnson might
leave things unresolved tonight but
would the outcome of two key bar
elections later this month change minds
could boris johnson be judged to have
lied on partygate or is this
conservative party determined to place
its faith in the man who delivered a
landslide barely three years ago samko
sky news westminster
oh well the clock is ticking just around
40 minutes until we can bring you uh the
result of that vote time now to recap
some of today's other main headlines
because there was a high profile
intervention earlier when the senior
former cabinet minister jeremy hunt
said
this he said conservative mps know in
our hearts we are not giving the british
people the leadership they deserve and
we are set to lose the next general
election
he then went on to say this today's
decision is change or lose i will be
voting for change so pretty clear there
from jeremy hunt that he's going to be
voting against the prime minister in the
confidence vote and also there was this
from the former government minister
jesse norman
he said the sue grey report showed mr
johnston presided over a culture of
casual law breaking at 10 downing street
when going on to say to describe
yourself as vindicated by the report is
grotesque two figures who are
significant jeremy hunt because he's a
potential leadership candidate jesse
norman because you know he's worked with
boris johnson for quite a long time and
yet that was an eviscerating letter that
he published explaining why he's not
going to be voting in favor of his
leadership well we're joined now by our
political correspondent ali er fortescue
has been outside the room where all that
voting was taking place did you get much
of a flavor about what mps were thinking
i have to say i wish i had a clearer
answer for you but i've been in there
all day and i'm hearing completely
different things from different people
you know some rebels this morning were
pretty downbeat i think they sort of
thought that they could persuade some of
their colleagues to come on their side
but they didn't manage to do that but
then others seemed a bit more optimistic
we were as you say you know on committee
corridor this short corridor where they
all queue up about 30 or so um peter
bottomley the father of the house was
first in the queue he said no i never
tell anyone which way i'm voting then we
had roger gale the famous boris johnson
critic he was about fourth in the queue
happy to have got that spot and said
that it was a very painful thing to do
and i think you know no tory party
member wants to get rid of their leader
that's prime minister so i think it is
um it's been difficult and i think what
we've seen as mps going back to their
constituencies talking to constituents
and that i think has been a big concern
for a lot of them is that is boris
johnson not cutting through in the way
he used to and that was his big thing
that he was someone that could win those
red wool seats was someone that clearly
chimed with voters a lot of people i
think now thinking that maybe he's lost
his touch with the electorate it's quite
interesting isn't it because you are
just seeing this as you say disparate
views uh dehenna davidson
bishop auckland winning that seat for
the first time in 2019 saying that he's
got to go then alex stafford who was
sitting where you are a few moments ago
saying that mp for rather valley exactly
the man who's going to cut through in
the red wall it feels as if they are
i guess the challenge is how do you get
this party back together again yeah it
feels messy it feels disorganized
uncoordinated and therefore i think um
unpredictable you know 180 i think very
few mps think that he will reach that
threshold that's obviously a much higher
bar than 54 but even coming close you
know we talked about this all evening
could be mortally wounding and i can't
remember a
leader of the conservative party that
has really recovered from this sort of
vote i mean it's interesting isn't it
and beth rick b atlas creditor spoke to
nadine doris earlier on today she had
some pretty choice words to
say about jeremy hunt i think it's
probably worth actually playing you what
she said
jeremy hunt today has come out himself
i'm surprised you haven't mentioned this
has come out today himself and said that
he is time for change i think what he
means is it's time for him
and you know i don't want to talk about
individual personalities but what i
would say is that you can't say
repeatedly that you're not going to
challenge the prime minister while as a
war in ukraine and on the day russia
fires rockets into keeve decide that it
is time for a change of leader
oh wow pretty punchy for nadine dory's
uh there and i guess this is one of the
questions isn't it you know you do have
uh this party that is effectively you
know ripping yourself apart these
confidence votes are always going to be
difficult for mps and
what do you see as a path forward yeah
and i think you know this is a party
that has always been ruthless with its
leaders and has tried perhaps not to be
um but i think the other interesting
thing is and what some tour mps have
said is that there's no kind of clear
alternative and that's what the prime
minister was actually saying um from
part sources to the 1922 committee
earlier was that there's no clear
alternative here there's no obvious
successor and i think people that are
against the prime minister think that
they the timing isn't good for them they
haven't had enough time to sort of plot
to show a clear alternative and of
course you've got those two by-elections
coming up at wakefield interiton some
people thought they might wait until
after those results because if they were
bad i guess it would give them a bit
more momentum and i think also some mt
mps are just very fatigued by you know
there's always been wait for the su gray
report wait for party gate wait for the
met police investigation
i think some people just want to get
this over with but as you say you know
these go these are two by elections in
very different parts of the country
they're lib dem think they can overturn
a 24 000 majority in tivot and hunterton
wakefield in the north um
red wall seat that labour hope they can
take back if they lose both those seats
in one night that's obviously very bad
but under the current rules there could
be no leadership contest like this for
another year uh really interesting stuff
uh good talk ali uh thank you very much
you are watching our special program on
tonight's confidence vote in boris
johnson coming up we're gonna have more
from westminster you'll be pleased to
hear as we wait for the result
of that vote we're gonna be talking to
the trade secretary anne-marie trevelyan
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome back to this confidence
vote special the vote in the prime
minister was triggered after 15 percent
of conservative mps wrote to the chair
of the 1922 committee of backbench mp's
that's the grand brady and called for
the prime minister's resignation let's
have a little listen now to how he then
announced the news
the threshold of 15 of the parliamentary
party seeking a vote of confidence in
the prime minister has been passed
therefore a vote of confidence will take
place
within the rules of the 1922 committee
that vote will take place this evening
in the house of commons between six and
eight o'clock
and we will announce the result shortly
thereafter
there will be arrangements for proxy
votes for any colleagues who can't be
present in person
in westminster and will notify
colleagues of those arrangements in the
near future
so how does the no confidence process
work
to trigger about 15 as we just said of
conservative mps that's 54 in total have
to submit no confidence letters so in
the vote more than half of the party's
mps that's 180 need to vote against the
prime minister in order to remove him
and if that happens there's then a
leadership contest and boris johnson is
barred from running in it but if he wins
according to the rules as they stand he
is safe for
a year
so that is the current ball so it was
quite interesting to hear uh sir roger
gail tell me uh earlier on uh in the
program that there's nothing to stop
them changing the rules that he could
see that uh potentially uh being an
outcome to allow them to hold another
vote of confidence that in the prime
minister if he gets past this one so it
might not be the end yet we'll see uh
this morning there was the shock
resignation of course of the prime
minister's own anti-corruption champion
john penrose said it was clear that
boris johnson had broken the ministerial
code over partygate and that he should
have resigned
sue grey report says so in terms it says
there are major problems with leadership
and he hasn't addressed that at all in
his response i think at that point it's
pretty clear that he has broken the
ministerial code in a very material way
and at that point hey i'm afraid it's
normally a resignation matter for the
minister concerned and but also clearly
i as the anti-corruptions are can't
carry on
in that role
until unless this is addressed it feels
now like a question of when not if but
we will have to wait and see what the
result is if he has a thumping victory
this evening um then that might be
different but it you know at the moment
in so far as anyone can tell
it feels like the beginning of the end
feels like the beginning of the end
probably
one of the most stinging criticisms of
the prime minister because of mr
penrose's role as the anti-corruption
champion at the same time though
unsurprisingly there has also been some
strong support for the prime minister in
particular from some of his members of
cabinet among them jacob rees-mogg
dominic raab and nadine doris all told
sky news that they believe that boris
johnson is going to comfortably survive
this evening's fate
i don't think anyone's particularly
surprised that this has happened uh this
morning and the 15 barrier is a
relatively low barrier uh to achieve
so
i don't think we should be that
surprised by it nobody has had forced me
to come out to support
an exceptional good forward-looking
prime minister he needs to remind people
of what he's achieved
and the election victory was a very
personal victory there are a lot of
members of parliament who owe their
seats directly to boris johnson i hope
that mps will overwhelmingly support him
i think
i believe that they will
that will i hope as well but draw a line
behind
some of this has been speculation for
weeks now we've got a whole packed
agenda we've got a general election in
less than two years packed a gender on
leveling up on skills of course the cost
of living
the crime and law enforcement which is
one of my areas working with pretty
patel or we can turn inwards with what i
think the public will view as a rather
self-indulgent bout of talking to
ourselves and so i think it's important
people get behind the prime minister and
i'm confident they will i'm not worried
at all in fact i'd like to get this vote
out of the way so that we can get on
focusing on the issues that really need
to be focused on 14 million people voted
for the prime minister in a general
election the biggest vote that a prime
minister conservative prime minister has
had since margaret thatcher i find it
utterly bizarre that a small number of
mps think that they can overrule that
vote
that that vote of 14 million people it's
quite something that they think they can
do that and so you know let's get this
vote done let's let's move on tomorrow
8 36 the current time and if things do
stick to schedule that means that it is
less than half an hour
until we find out the result of the
confidence vote in boris johnson and it
does feel that speaking to mps one of
the key things that they're voting on is
whether or not they believe that boris
johnson is still an election winner alex
stafford the mp for royal valley saying
he's supporting the pm because he thinks
he can win over some of those critical
seats to henry davidson uh the mp for
bishop auckland saying the opposite and
uh really of course we've got the big
test coming up the big test at the
election because there are two critical
by-elections on the horizon in wakefield
the kind of classic red wall territory
that labour is hoping to take back off
the conservatives and also in tibetan
and honeton which the lib dems are
hoping to take
nick martin our people and politics
correspondent has been in wakefield
trying to find out what voters there
make of boris johnson
in the next few weeks this cathedral
city in west yorkshire will vote for a
new mp
and the result could tell us a lot about
how people feel about the prime minister
and his government
cities like wakefield which were labor
for so long turned tori in the last
general election and that helped to
secure victory for boris johnson but now
a recent poll suggests that labour are
20 points ahead here and if that's true
then the conservatives could be heading
for a crushing defeat in this
by-election
it's been a bruising time for boris
johnson and the lockdown parties and
subsequent fines seem to hit a nerve
with some voters the things that he's
done put us in lockdown then have his
own party
he's just gone against his own word so
it's disgusting really why was he
ignoring the restrictions why was he
ignoring the rules is it the partying
that's really
got you upset it's not helped his case
does it it's not helped it no
if it came to a general election a vote
now
would you be happy for him to continue
as a prime minister
the tory win here in 2019 was remarkable
labor after all had held this seat since
the 1930s
the question is whether after everything
that's happened have they got enough
support to win again it just comes
across as a bit bumbling a bit idiotic
at times and
end of day he's going to live and down
his sword and he made the rules and he's
decided to break him
so you you had faith in him you had
faith him in the beginning you were
willing to vote for him but it's the
party thing is it
that's that's dented that faith
i would definitely say the party that if
he can't keep his own rules he can't be
trusted and trust is the main thing that
you need as these kids growing up you
want the best for their for their future
and given that you know how he's led
over the past few years it's not been
great
support for politicians can flourish and
wither in the blink of an eye annetta
ford is a florist in the city and she's
also a loyal conservative
what he's done since brexit covet
and ukrainian war
um
that is that is the main thing so i'm
looking on the bigger picture not just a
glass of wine and i've i got that
confidence i have to say
yeah
so you believe that
going forward he should remain prime
minister because he's getting more right
than wrong
well yeah in a nutshell yeah
a defeat in wakefield would pile even
more pressure on the prime minister at a
time when confidence in his leadership
is being tested to the limits nick
martin sky news wakefield
martin uh reporting there well there's
lots more to come as we head towards the
crucial result it's expected around uh
nine o'clock so that is bang on 20
minutes time but we've got lots more
online as well so you can just scan the
qr code that is on your screen right now
in order to read all the latest news and
analysis in our politics hub
you're watching sky news our special
programme on the confidence vote coming
up we are going to have more on the
prime minister's future mps have
finished voting we're expecting the
results in just 20 minutes time
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
police have just made their first move
and they're bothering firing us
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
there are hundreds of these turbines but
thousands more across gansu
[Music]
that's what's left of the north tunnel
where the north koreans exploded five
nuclear warheads
[Music]
and this is a show of strength at a time
when china is more fragile than it has
been at any time in recent years
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
the train station the airport they're
both closed we're not sure about the
roads we've seen reports that they are
being blocked by police so we're going
to try and find a way out of wuhan
after five days stranded here this is
deliverance we help you understand the
world with us
tom cheshire sky news beijing
[Music]
the enormous explosion has just come
down
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
you either live and recover or you die
[Music]
well now we really are into the final
stretch of the waiting game the no
confidence vote in the prime minister
which ended at eight o'clock and those
results are expected very shortly at 9
00 pm is when we are expecting things to
run although of course these things can
have a life of their own well we're
joined now by the conservative
commentator tim montgomery um thank you
very much for uh being uh with us what's
your best prediction i know that i'm
really kind of putting you on the spot
here with the result announced
imminently but what's your best
prediction for how things are going to
go
well sophie i've learned in politics
when donald trump becomes president and
jeremy corbyn becomes labour leader not
to make predictions so why i'm going to
answer your question i don't know but i
think i think we're probably in the
region of 120 to 140 conservative mps
rebelling against him i think he will
survive the leadership vote uh tonight
but if you have that sort of degree of
rebellion you know well over a hundred
tory mps losing confidence in your
leadership i think your days as tory
leader are numbered i think the thing
that is holding tory mps back from
absolutely finishing the prime minister
off today is a lack of consensus about a
likely successor but you know
talking off um off camera
off microphone as i'm sure you've done
today there are a lot of conservative
mps there are a lot of conservative
ministers who while publicly backing the
prime minister are telling me that um
when there is an opportunity that the
the the moment is right that they think
his time is up yeah to be honest so i
have experience a bit of the same like
some of the mps who have been notched up
as supportive of the prime minister on
twitter accounts are actually saying a
rather different thing to me in
private but look we're going to see how
the vote goes because it could go
either way and it does feel as though
supporters of the prime minister are
quite confident that he is going to win
and if he does get over the line do you
see any scenario where he resigns
no
one thing i think about the prime
minister is that he will be have to be
um pulled you know kicking screaming out
of downing street i think he's wanted
this job was that he he said he wanted
to be world king i think was the
expression he's wanted to be world king
for a very long time so i think it will
be very difficult to
get him to resign but you know a lot of
people are saying well it's 12 months
until there can be
another tory leadership race anyone who
knows the conservative party knows that
when it comes to rules and principles
it's infinitely flexible that's why it's
the most successful political party in
the world
if if conservative mps decide after the
forthcoming by-elections in honorton and
tiverton and wakefield that the prime
minister is no longer electoral asset if
we begin to see cabinet resignations
which i think will happen quite soon if
the opinion polls continue to show that
the majority of the british people don't
trust a word that he says anymore all of
those things i think are true the
conservative party will find a way of
ousting him his days are numbered the
conservative party doesn't wound a
leader as it will do today without
knowing that
certainly sure afterwards it will kill
that leader's premiership and so and it
is just a question now of when uh rather
than if uh the prime minister is toast
uh at the same time i guess a supporters
uh boris johnson would say look this is
the guy who won a landslide election he
is a man who has managed to speak to
voters that had the conservative party
frankly hasn't been able to speak to
before at all uh by other leaders uh so
why on earth would they want to go
through you know the the difficult
process of a leadership election
and all that that may entail when you've
already got someone who is a proven
election winner
2019 uh was a long time ago sophie um i
think since then of course we've all
lived through lockdown we've all missed
funerals and weddings and you know a
whole range of um
very intimate family events
because we've abided by the rules and
the prime minister hasn't i think the
reputation he had a few years ago when
he won that historic general election
victory those things just don't apply
anymore and and let's not overstate the
contribution that the the boris johnson
made to winning that election theresa
may actually made significant progress
in sort of northern uh previously labor
seats uh at the election before even
though she fell short of a majority look
at australia look at america look across
the western world conservative center
right parties are doing a lot better in
traditionally working class seats
left to center
liberal parties are doing better in
wealthier seats the whole electoral
geography of the world is is changing to
a significant extent uh i don't think
boris johnson uh will
will be able to prove that he's the big
difference that some of his supporters
think there are global trends taking
place at the conservative party and will
i think be better place with a leader
who can be trusted with voters who who
thinks that who voters think when he
says stuff they can believe it and that
is the big problem with boris johnson
consistently opinion polls now say that
voters don't trust him and you don't
want to go into an election with a
leader who whatever they say whether
it's tax or climate change or cost of
living isn't believed let's talk a
little bit about potential successes now
some people might think this is
premature
of course but it's pretty clear from
what you've said that you think that
this is the beginning of the end uh even
if boris johnson survives
rishi sunak
for many people was mortally wounded
this year there is no clear
obvious
successor to the prime minister is there
um no and i think if there was a clear
successor you know there would be no
doubt about the outcome of this
leadership race i think we've agreed
sophie that a number of tory mps who
publicly declared for the prime minister
don't actually have faith in him
and they are just waiting for uh an
alternative unity candidate that they
can they can back and i think once there
is an alternative that's clear i think
they will back that person and gun to my
head
um if you insisted that i uh name the
sort of person who would win i think
you'd be looking at someone like the
education secretary nadim
uh zahawi
the conservative party is incredibly
divided at the moment it's an
embarrassment that i as a committed
conservative have to come onto programs
like yours and talk about this um a
fractious a very split conservative
party if we have any chance at the next
election of avoiding a kia stam and
nicola sturgeon coalition at the next
general election we have to find a
leader who can unite the party's warring
factions it will be someone who is
supported on all sides of the party like
nadeem zaha we will be able to unite the
party but um don't ask me to bet more
than a fiver on that outcome but if um
that would be my best bet at that moment
that's a pretty small amount of money it
does perhaps say a little bit about the
confidence in your prediction i think
there tim montgomery thank you very much
uh good to uh talk to you today
well you are now looking at live
pictures from inside the 1922 uh
committee meeting room this of course
it's where things were all taking place
you can see there nadeem saharawi the
person that tim montgomery was just
talking about as potential successor to
uh boris johnson and the room starting
to
fill up there our political editor beth
rigby is with us as we wait for the
results of that confidence vote in the
prime minister nine minutes if they run
on time of course which which they may
this is bringing back memories for me of
um
the theresa may confidence vote yes and
you'll remember that she survived it she
lost a she won 63
of the vote she lost 37 of support
um
she didn't have a working majority
really she had to rely on the confidence
and supply of the dep so she's in a
weaker position if you like as a prime
minister than boris johnson is in that
he has a 79-seat majority but you'll
remember that she won that vote
um
117 of her own mp said that they didn't
have the confidence in her and then six
months later she had to resign because
she just got
caught in all of those votes in the
commons where the party hadn't managed
to oust her but they managed to do her
in
on the floor of the house instead she
had to stand down
and pave the way for johnson to to go on
and win that leadership election which i
guess is a really useful uh thing to
look at here because if he does of
course get to the 118 mark which people
expect him to the teresa main threshold
if you like is 133
uh people uh voting against him if you
look at the percentages that you were
just talking about so i guess in some
ways do you think that is a threshold
well actually
my very clever colleague tom raynor was
just talking to me about this outside
and he'd worked out that
to to to do better than theresa may or
to level with trees mate boris johnson
needs the support uh needs the support
of also he needs less than
133 mps to vote against him yes so
that's his threshold uh anything uh
under that then he will have better
theresa may in this particular
confidence vote so let's see where the
numbers uh come in and how do you think
the confidence is uh among boris
johnson's supporters you know we spoke
to kit malta's house he said he think
there's gonna be a thumping victory uh
which i have to say i thought that was
you know really nailing his currents to
the maths with this vote so imminent um
do you think that there's a bit of
confidence among them
on both look on both sides whether it be
rebels or allies the the one consensus
in this riven party now this very
divided party is that both sides think
that the likelihood is boris johnson
survives the vote so this is the one
thing
amid all these divisions that everyone
seems to agree on um
but in terms of predicting where it
lands the reason it's so difficult is
because the government payroll you've
got 160 to 170 mps who will always say
that they will vote for the prime
minister but they might not follow
through with that particularly the
leadership handicipe
some of these people may be thinking
that if they aren't going to be hoping
to stand
for the leader
in a few months time then actually
publicly supporting boris johnson
presenting yourself as a unifying
character might not be a bad thing
exactly so so it's it's hard to it's
hard to read where the vote goes i think
it's fair to say that should boris
johnson uh lose this vote that would be
genuinely
a political earthquake i mean it would
be absolutely astonishing
for him to actually lose the vote i
think what people are looking at
that could happen though i mean i'm not
ruling it out either i'm just saying
that it would be a big
big surprise
but what people are looking at is how
how tight will it be how many mps rebel
against him as i was saying earlier if
it's over a hundred
mps that means he's lost the majority of
the back benches uh if it's you know a
hundred and thirty-three mps uh he's not
interested in worse than teresa someone
described me as anything over 120 it
would be the start of a long and slow
death for boris johnson so it does feel
that there's different graduations if
you like yeah i i mean i mean what's
what would be a good if you you know if
you ask someone uh
some of his allies uh those working
closely with him in government what's a
good result i mean it's keeping it to
double digits really and not and not
going over that that 100 threshold but
the expectation management was something
today wasn't when you had cabinet
ministers coming out and saying he only
needs to win by one vote yeah that was
the matter settled and you all turned
the page and i think look that really is
wishful thinking whatever happens
tonight whatever the result is tonight
this is another staging post for boris
johnson in terms of what his detractors
would say is now the terminal decline
and what his supporters would say is an
opportunity to try and rebuild and to
draw a line under but and to draw a line
under it but what is clear from this is
if you look back through history
conservative party leaders who face a
confidence vote in the end it does for
them either at a ballot box
with john major with theresa may where
she had to stand down or margaret
thatcher she also
had to resign so this is bad news
there's no way you can spin this as a
prime minister as this being a good
thing to happen to you uh the best he
can hope for is that he manages to keep
that rebellion down and he manages to
somehow rebuild afterwards but a lot of
it will depend on how he handles himself
after this vote and you saw we were
talking about it earlier that this blue
on blue infighting and this very very
personal
acerbic attacks between say nadine doris
who is one of the key uh boris johnson
lieutenants and and jeremy hunt who is
now opposed to the prime minister and
has leadership ambitions
himself uh these do not help rebuild the
party they just exacerbate
the divisions and where nadine dorries
is right is when she says divided
parties don't win elections the public
see it and they lose confidence in the
party because they think well if you
can't run yourselves how are you going
to run our country
we're looking at those live pictures
from the 1922 committee room you can see
there the mps who managed to bag the
front row seats a couple more just
sitting around relaxed having a chat
no microphones in a minute unfortunately
i'd love to know what uh they were
saying each other now you can't see it
here but somewhere at the back of that
room will be the lobby will be
you know 30 to 40 journalists
unfortunately i never get to go in i
quite like to be in there
sit here no i like i like sitting here
talking to you but uh it's um it's quite
a it's quite an experience to kind of be
in the in the room
it's one of those kind of westminster
traditions 1922 committee uh isn't it
which effectively kind of governs the
rules of the conservative parliamentary
uh party there's been talk as well
haven't there about uh the fact that if
he wins this vote according to the rules
boris johnson has been immune for a year
that is a very leadership challenge so
on paper
it would feel that he could come out of
it with a strength
it's interesting that because uh there
was an attempt earlier this year to
change the rules to change it so you
didn't have to wait for another year
before calling another vote but that
kind of got torpedoed and didn't happen
but some mps have said to me today
that regardless of this rule if you end
up towards the end of the year and the
majority of conservative mps are calling
for the prime minister to stand down or
they've put letters in it would be very
hard for the 22 to not to not call
another vote but convention states
there's michael fabricant there uh
convention states that um
that he is safe
for another year and this is also why
it's curious about the timing of this
vote because if you were a rebel trying
to orchestrate uh the point of maximum
weakness for the prime minister
kind of the monday back after the
platinum jubilee whilst you've still got
two potentially fatal by-elections for
him to run would not necessarily be the
moment that you would want the vote
because at the moment he can still stand
okay hey i'm a proven voter winner and
you know
he you know 40 million
uh people voted for boris johnson you
know you're dozens of mps ignoring the
will of the people you know that that
that argument's quite hard to make if
you lose two uh by-elections in quick
success do you think interestingly on
that on the timing because as you said
you know it's not the perfect timing by
any stretch of the imagination do you
think that perhaps here we go you can
see the officers coming in and that is
to graham brady in the middle picking
out good evening
let's listen uh i can report as
returning officer
that 359 ballots were cast
no spoiled ballots
that the vote in favor
of having confidence in boris johnson's
leader was 211 votes and the vote
against was 148 votes
and therefore i can announce that the
parliamentary party does have confidence
[Applause]
well there you go that is the results
of the confidence motion the cheers
there the support
for the prime minister but just look at
those numbers do you have confidence in
boris johnson as leader of the
conservative party 211 mps said yes
148 mps said no that's a majority of
just 63 and really in context that is
quite astonishing
133 was the number that he would have to
get
to do better than theresa may so that is
a lot worse than theresa may did in
percentage terms
and of course she resigned as leader in
the month after that confidence vote uh
people supporting at boris johnson were
saying they were hoping he would make it
to double figures so
get the rebellion under 100 mps well
that certainly hasn't happened
148 conservative mps and they don't have
confidence in the prime minister beth
well if you were in downing street
tonight looking at that figure you are
going to be disappointed by that that is
a very disappointing result for boris
johnson a majority of just 63 148
of his parliamentary party have signaled
that they do not have confidence in him
as prime minister that is
definitely on the upper end of
estimations that i had been hearing
today as i was saying earlier a vote of
over a hundred
no's
that is losing the majority of his
parliamentary party and the question
that comes from that vote is how on
earth can boris johnson really corral
the party get legislation through
148 of his own backbenchers say that
they no longer have confidence in him
you only need 40 mps to consistently
vote against boris johnson for him to
lose his majority in there you have
148 that will give him plenty of food
for thought tonight i should say though
to sophie that the prime minister has
been very clear all of the way through
this as have his allies that he has no
intention of resigning uh unless he is
forced out of office but that is
a deeply uncomfortable result for him
and you have to ask after that are we
now going to watch a period of time
where boris johnson is in office he
survives in downing street but he is not
really in power he does not have the
authority over his party 148 of his own
mps uh say that they don't have
confidence in him you've got to remember
that the government payroll though is
160 to 107
so you know he's bought in a lot of
support from the government payroll
there but 148 against him that is deeply
disappointing and certainly if you look
at the expectation management from
number 10 they are going to be shaken by
that figure 148 that is certainly at the
upper end of what people were predicting
and as beth was saying it really does
feel that there are going to be
questions about how he's going to govern
going forward when uh the public know
that 148 of his own mps don't have
confidence in him
and of course the
working majority that he has in getting
legislation through as well yeah and i
mean when you look at those votes um
my colleague louie's just done the the
calculation from me we think it's about
58
of his mps have backed him which tells
you that uh
58.7 so 41 have not so he's done far
worse than theresa may did back in uh
29. significantly worse as you said uh
thank you uh beth well let's go live now
to the houses of uh parliament where our
deputy political editor sam coats is in
uh central lobby for us sam
thank you very much indeed sophie yes uh
one uh cabinet loyalist said to me a
moment ago that is more disappointing
than we were expecting so for the first
reaction we have uh two mps two members
uh people who sit around the cabinet
table nadine zahawi he's the education
secretary michelle donald who also works
in that department um nadine let's start
with you this is a disappointment can
you say that
well i think the
important thing to remember is whichever
side
of the argument you're on on this
the one thing we all believe in is
democracy
that was a ballot the prime minister won
handsomely
i think the important thing to remember
is that we only are able to deliver if
we are united i hope we can draw a line
under this now and focus on delivery
okay i'm going to stop you there 41
of people of tory mps have tonight said
that they have no confidence in boris
johnson how can you stand here and say
that is a handsome result
because
those 41 that you refer to
are equally democratic
they believe in this party they believe
in democracy
50 plus one is a majority right boris
did much better than that
we draw a line and we move on because
we've got two years to demonstrate in
that nation that we can deliver on the
economy we've got to deal with the
battle against the global battle against
inflation we've got to deal with the
backlog of the nhs safer streets and of
course war in europe what do you think
president zielinski will be thinking
tonight he'll be punching the air
because he knows his great ally boris
johnson will be prime minister tomorrow
morning that's what we've got to focus
on what michelle and i are doing is
focusing on skills schools family
because boris johnson has mandated us to
deliver on those things these are big
priorities for the nation your viewers
will be thinking about what are these
cabinet ministers going to do to deliver
over the next two years
we've won the vote tonight we move on
and we build this country's economy
because we have to recover from covert
and of course war in europe michelle 41
what do you think what's your message to
the 41 of your colleagues tonight that
voted no confidence in boris johnson so
i think now is the time to move on now
is not the time for self-indulgent naval
gazing now is the time to deliver it's
what we're doing as ministers in the
department for education it's what we're
doing across government on the people's
priorities tackling that nhs backlog
helping people with the cost of living
these are the things that people are
concerned about day in day out why do
you think the 41
was so high so i think we've had a
democratic vote tonight boris johnson
has won now we need to move on and we
need to get focused on delivery and
that's what this government is going to
do over the next two years and deliver
for the british public and tackle the
issues that constituents are contacting
me every day about
worried about their energy bills worried
about that cost of living we saw a big
package where we gave additional support
just a couple of weeks ago and that's
the type of things that you can expect
from this government final question
nadine zahawi do you really expect all
of that 41 that 200
that 148 uh strong bunch of tory mp
rebels against the prime minister to now
shut up and get on uh with supporting
the prime minister you're in for a
protected period of tory civil war
what i expect from my colleagues which i
know they believe i've spoken to pretty
much all of my colleagues
is democracy right we know we have a
constitution in the party we've
exercised that today
i hope we can now draw a line against
all the speculation from you know the
media and the rest of the sort of the
the uh twitter arty and everyone else
and focus on delivery all of my
colleagues whichever way they voted know
that we win the election when we are
united people don't vote for divided
parties that's my message we're
democrats
above everything else and i think you'll
find every colleague even those who
voted against the prime minister tonight
will agree with that statement thank you
for watching dean nadine
there you have it sophie the first
reaction out of the blocks is that boris
johnson has won handsomely even though
148 tory mps voted tonight that they
have no confidence in boris johnson
uh there you go sam handsome victory uh
indeed thank you very much for uh that
well let's bring beth rigby back in uh
shall we at this point i think it is
interesting isn't it listening uh to
backers of boris johnson there
saying that now is the time to move on
it's time to stop the naval gazing
148
mp's voting no confidence that's going
to be impossible yeah the more right the
more i digest the figure the the worst
the worse it looks i mean
nadeem says hari's saying that it's time
to draw a line under this you can't draw
a line under it when 41
of your own mps
say they have no confidence in you that
is in black and white it's set in stone
the vote has happened it's a matter
of record now this is a prime minister
who has lost the confidence of 41
of his parliamentary party you know the
majority by some of his backbenchers uh
it's worse than theresa may how she did
uh in 2019 and you'll remember six
months later she had to resign jim
picard my former colleague at the ft
just tweeting out that it's a lower
percentage terms in terms
percentage-wise and john major in 95
and margaret thatcher in 90 1990 so had
the hope been for the prime minister's
allies to turn the page and draw a line
on it you just simply can't when the
rebellion is as big as that and it
raises questions about
how on earth he commands the commons how
does he drive through legislation when
so many of his mps now say they don't
have confidence in him as prime minister
anymore it feels trustworthy that uh so
far allies of the prime minister have uh
tried to say that this is effectively uh
remainers disgruntled uh remainers uh
trying to uh
rehash old arguments but the fact that
the number is so high as you say 40
percent 148. it's just that means it's
just accurate that that that means that
that is a that's a cross-section of the
party uh from all wings of 40 absolutely
if you if you if you look at um
if you if you actually think about the
one nation group of of conservatives
which is the caucus within the
parliamentary party which are basically
remainers etc i mean that group is 50 to
60 maximum this is 159 people people
like steve baker who was a lead in
brexit here that helped put boris
johnson in
to
uh number 10. he's publicly said he
won't support him andrew ledsome again
another brexiteer that was a champion of
boris johnson jesse norman
who was a champion of boris johnson
penny mordent
who um backed jeremy hunt in the
leadership campaign and and was ousted
from cabinet by boston she was a key
brexiteer so you just can't say that
it's just not accurate uh thank you uh
beth let's go live to the house of
parliament now because uh mps are
starting to come out of that committee
room uh sam cates uh has got roger gale
with him another strong critic
of the prime minister uh i'm interested
to know what he made of that result
that's right sophie uh roger gail indeed
one of the 148 um sir roger you've heard
the response of boris johnson allies
they're making an argument that he won
and wins a win and that
the nature of democracy means that issue
this issue is now settled about boris
johnson's future is it unfortunately the
issue can't be settled like that
um a third over a third
of the parliamentary party has expressed
no confidence in the prime minister
now we have a job of work to do
we've got to get on and govern sam we've
got to
push through the conservative
legislation
but we are pledged to enact and we will
do that
and i'm not one of those who believes in
a vote strike or anything like that
we don't all agree with all the
legislation nobody ever does
but we have a job to do and we have to
get on and the electorate will expect us
to do that but that is separate
from our reaction to the prime minister
okay forgive me let me just try and
clarify something
are you saying
that
given tonight's result you accept that
boris johnson
should and can continue to be prime
minister
for
take the conservative party into the
next election
no i've expressed my view very clearly
indeed
so why don't you do it i don't believe
that he should take the party into the
next general election and i think
there are other elephant traps down the
road
two by-elections coming up
the privileges committee report in the
autumn
but there are a lot of hurdles ahead
and i think
a prime minister
of honour would look at the figures
accept the fact
that he has lost the
support of a significant proportion of
his party and consider his position but
i don't think he'll do that exactly and
because of that because
he is unlikely to resign in pretty much
any circumstance sir roger gail my
question to you is
will you now retire your campaign to
unseat him and accept that for the next
year at least he is
saying you're misrepresenting the
situation i have no campaign to unseat
him
i have a personal view that mr johnson
is not the fit and proper person to be
prime minister of the united kingdom but
i'm elected as a conservative member of
parliament
on a manifesto that we need to deliver
so i will support the legislation but
don't expect me to support this prime
minister i cannot do that so you will
continue to say to voice your view in
the weeks and months ahead just as you
have been doing up to today's vote i was
elected to say what i think and i have
to continue to say what i think
and do you think that some of the other
members of the
sam um apologies we are going straight
to kiestarma who's giving his reaction
or to back boris johnson
the british public are fed up
fed up with a prime minister who
promises big but never delivers
fed up with a prime minister who's
presided over a culture of lies and law
breaking at the heart of government
fed up with a prime minister who is
utterly unfit for the great office that
he holds
conservative mps
made their choice tonight
they have ignored the british public
and hitched themselves and their party
firmly to boris johnson and everything
that he represents
the conservative party now believes that
good government focused on improving
lives is too much to ask
the conservative government
now believes that breaking the law is no
impediment to making the law
the conservative party now believes that
the british public have no right to
expect honest politicians
over the weekend
the whole country celebrated the queen's
platinum jubilee
it was a tribute
to 70 years of humility decency
and respect
a reminder of our common cause to build
a better country for ourselves our
children and our grandchildren
it is grotesque that the very next day
the conservative party has chosen to
throw that sense of duty and those
values on the bonfire
the choice in british politics is
clearer tonight
than ever before
a labour party united under my
leadership with a plan to ensure that
britain is never again plunged into a
cost of living crisis
focused on growing the economy so we can
afford world-class schools and hospitals
and determined to restore trust in
politics
or a conservative party that is divided
propping up boris johnson with no plan
to tackle the issues
facing you
and your family
i don't claim that i or my party will
get everything right
but i promise that when we don't
we will always be honest with you
we will prioritize your prosperity and
your security
and we will treat you with the respect
you deserve from your politicians
i promise that together we will end the
fast we've seen in recent months
that we will once again put the country
first get rid of this tired out-of-touch
government
and get britain back on track
thank you
kirsten they're giving his reaction to
the results of that confidence vote
speaking at labour hq you can see that
he was directly appealing to the voters
saying that he and the labour party will
in his words get this country back on
track uh after the events of recent
months uh just to recap if you are just
joining us the results just on your
screen now at
211 conservative mps voting to say they
have confidence in the prime minister
and 148
saying that they do not that's a
majority of just 63
more than 40 percent
of the conservative parliamentary party
voting against the prime minister far
worse than teresa made it
in the confidence vote that eventually
led
to her resigning as prime minister so a
difficult uh result there for boris
johnson now allies of course say that
it's time to draw a line under matters
that he's won
that the naval gazing should stop
whether or not that is actually able to
happen of course that's another question
we can try and find out we can go live
to the houses of parliament and talk to
our deputy political editor uh sam coats
he's in central lobby he's busy
colouring uh conservative mps to try and
get their reaction
to what just happened sam
that's right sophie way welcome back to
central lobby which is buzzing at the
moment largely uh because the danny
street operation has managed to get out
quite a lot of cabinet ministers quite a
supportive mps people to just talk up
boris johnson in the face of that result
which in private loyalists will admit is
a worse result than they are expected
but in public they're talking tough
talking about the prime minister
carrying on and their win is a win so
let's talk to one supporter boris
johnson scott benton blackpool uh mp um
you're uh you voted in favor of boris
johnson continuing in post
41 of the party tonight voted no
confidence in boris johnson do you feel
how do you feel about them
well this evening was all about drawing
a line under the cloud for the last two
or three months has been a cloud over
boris's leadership tonight's a good
night not just for the conservative
party not just for boris johnson but for
the country because we can finally draw
a line under the issue and move on my
constituents don't care about the title
tackle in westminster which colleagues
have fallen out with whom they care
about local school investment going into
the local hospital and if they can get a
well-paid job the line has been drawn
under the issue and we need to focus on
the qualities of british people and
deliver on what matters for them i think
if we really had the result for 20
minutes so i think we can talk about it
just a little longer four out of ten
conservative mps voted that they have no
confidence in boris johnson fair enough
it's a win but why can't you even
acknowledge that that wasn't very good
for him why can't you just say those
words no i can't acknowledge of course i
support boyce johnson would i'd like the
majority to be higher for him this
evening of course i would but as a
conservative party we do one thing very
well and that's uniting and fighting the
opposition
this evening the lesson from margaret
thatcher in 1989 the lesson from john
major in 1975 the lesson from theresa
may in 2019 did you unite and uh keep
them in post or win the next election
after an event for two thirds of the
last century conservative party has been
in power we have a natural party of
government what we need to do after this
evening's vote however colleagues voted
is understand each other speak to each
other but more importantly
draw a line under the situation and move
on boris has won a majority he's renewed
his mandate not just to serve as party
leader but to serve as prime minister
for the whole of our united kingdom he
now needs a space to deliver on those
priorities like he has in the past i'm
curious what you think of certain
individuals that came out against boris
johnson particularly jeremy hunt he was
out pretty strongly this morning why do
you think he did what he did today well
jeremy is a very accomplished politician
i'm sure there's a role for him to play
in this conservative government he is a
big beast we need to utilize all the
talents within the party do i think
jeremy hunt's the best person to lead
the party or the country no i don't i
think that's boris johnson that's why i
voted for him but whoever the
conservative party leader is has my
support and i think colleagues need to
listen to the message given by
colleagues this evening back boris and
support him on delivering on those
priorities and the concerns of british
people leveling up investing in public
services and providing people with help
to get them through this cost of living
crisis that's what we expect from the
prime minister and he now needs to
deliver
do you think that the 41 who voted no
confidence in boris johnson will do that
does a little bit of you worry that
having got the taste for rebellion the
bit between their teeth they won't shut
up and draw a line under it tonight no i
don't think that will be the case at all
there's a conservative party there's one
thing which interests us that is serving
our constituencies serving the country
and serving this country and there's
only one way we can do that and that's
by being in power heaven forbid if the
labour government were to be elected led
by kirsten and the catastrophe that
would inflict upon this country we now
need to unite understand each other and
support boris and that's what i would
implore all colleagues and members of
the party to do just because i think it
was implied but i'll let you spell it
out do you think figures like jeremy
hunt were making the statements about
boris johnson setting out the position
because they had leadership ambitions
today well i can't speak for germa's
leadership ambitions colleagues
understandably have concerns about
direction of the party concerns about
how partygate has been handled but as i
say the time for those questions has now
passed boris has won a decisive vote
this evening and we need to move on the
country expects nothing less leaving
aside the questions about partygate what
are the specific concerns that you refer
to about the direction of the party
well some
cons some colleagues have a number of
concerns about the direction of party
and whether or not taxation is too high
whether or not their constituencies in
different parts of the country are
getting enough funding but has had a
tremendously difficult task getting us
through covered delivering brexit now of
course we have a war in europe and the
cost of living crisis so you can't keep
every colleague with you on every single
issue but we need to understand each
other learn and listen to what each
other has to say but ultimately boris
and his team decide the policy direction
we need to put our faith in them and
support them to deliver on the
priorities of the british people
standing at that microphone minutes
before you turned up with sir roger
gayle a veteran colleague of yours he
said that he wasn't going to shut up
about boris johnson he would continue
to talk about his views about boris
johnson despite tonight's result what's
your message to sir roger well that's
disappointing of course as a
conservative party we're interested in
serving the british people and
ultimately you can't do that from
opposition and i'm afraid if we keep
speaking to each other about who's best
to
lead the conservative party we won't be
doing our jobs effectively as mps so i'd
implore people like roger who i speak to
often in the tea room to put those
questions to one side and focus on the
bigger picture which is delivering on
those domestic priorities and keeping
labor out of power scott thank you very
much indeed there you have it a hope
that there is unity inside the
conservative party but really sophie i
think that's the question uh for tonight
with that margin of victory perhaps
narrower than many were expecting will
the conservative party buckle under as
people like scott benson think or hope
or will they contin will those
over 140 conservative mps who voted no
confidence in boris johnson continue to
speak out through all of those bumpy
points in the road ahead making boris
johnson's life and boris johnson's
ability to govern
that much harder
interesting uh sam it's been really
fascinating listening to some of the
interviews that you've been doing with
the mps so far
as well the boris johnson supporters
saying that they want to draw a line
under things but then of course people
like sir roger gail telling you that
they intend to keep speaking out what's
your best prediction sam about where
things could go from now
look i think we're at the we're at the
worst end of results there's no doubt
about that loyalists privately uh are
acknowledging that the number of rebels
is higher than they wanted to see
higher than they expected suggesting
that not only is there going to be an
ongoing problem but also in some senses
the whipping operation the uh attempt to
try and keep track of what tory mps were
doing wasn't good enough so i think one
of the first things that danny street
has got to do in the coming uh days and
weeks
is to work out what went wrong how they
perhaps underestimated the strength of
feeling it was only friday i'm told that
people in downing street were telling
cabinet colleagues bring it on we want
to see this face with no confidence
we're bored with the way that this is
gathering momentum in the press but
never seems to come to our head
we are confident that boris johnson
would win win comfortably and then we
can move on with the bold array of plans
that they say that they've got for the
near future
but instead what's happened today is
that a worse majority that boris johnson
has done worse than theresa may did uh
in her own vote of no confidence in 2019
why does that matter well it took about
five and a half months for her to end up
falling on her sword because the depth
of opposition to her just never went
away i think there are some who feel
that boris john that john major's
challenge uh by john redwood which led
to a
head-to-head contest between the two
ultimately drained some of his authority
away uh in the lead-up to the 1997
election leading to that
tory drubbing in that year
and you had of course uh
margaret thatcher who uh won evasive low
confidence and then fell on her sword so
these things history suggests these
things don't end well but boris johnson
is perhaps a more stubborn and more
determined his supporters would say uh
prime minister than many of those that
we've had uh in recent history it
is determined not to resign under pretty
much any circumstances
his allies have made that pretty clear
um but that doesn't mean that uh given
that he now potentially has a year uh in
which he cannot face another vote of no
confidence uh uh challenged by
conservative mps he's given uh afforded
the protection of 12 months protection
as a result of tonight's vote under the
current 1922 rules uh there is a
question of whether or not there are any
other hurdles that could prove fatal
now the most obvious challenge for boris
johnson in the coming weeks comes up in
about three weeks time uh where there
are twin by-elections one uh in
wakefield as the result of uh the
departure of an mp uh uh uh convicted
for sexual assault uh another uh down in
the south west uh where bill parish
resigned after looking at pornography
when he was searching for tractors uh in
the commons chamber now those two
by-elections are important uh wakefield
because it's a representative a red wool
seat might fall to labour and down in
the southwest that's a
that tibetan seat is a is a conservative
stronghold his current form never held
uh by any opposition uh early opposition
party uh but the lib devins look like
strong challengers lose both of those
and i think we will be right back here
in central lobby sophie discussing the
same question with boris johnson's
leadership
okay sam uh thank you very much indeed
we're going to leave you so you can go
and uh find some more conservative mps
to go and talk to uh so just to recap uh
the results of that all-important
conference vote the prime minister won
it at
211 mps voting to say they have
confidence in him but just look at the
numbers underneath 148 of his own mps
saying that they did not have confidence
in his leadership that's 40 percent of
the conservative party majority of just
uh 63. and i have to say you know some
of the mps who you know been contacting
me seeming to think that this
could be the beginning of the end for
the prime minister 130 was the top end
of survival that would be roughly
what theresa may
managed and that was roughly what
theresa may
managed to get when she faced her own
confidence vote which of course she then
resigned to
resign from later
although it is worth saying of course
that allies if the prime minister are
continuing to say that this is a win um
someone speaking on behalf of the prime
minister saying to me a decisive win
that renews the prime minister's mandate
and allows the government to focus
relentlessly
on the issues that concern our voters
and deliver on their priorities so that
is the line from at number 10 very
similar to the line that came from the
education secretary nadoom zahawi
who was saying earlier two hours on sky
news that the prime minister just needed
to get a simple majority of just one in
order to win this vote
50 plus one is a majority right boris
did much better than that
we draw a line and we move on because
we've got two years to demonstrate in
that nation that we can deliver on the
economy we've got to deal with the
battle against the global battle against
inflation we've got to deal with the
backlog of the nhs safer streets and of
course war in europe what do you think
president zielinski will be thinking
tonight could be punching the air
because he knows his great ally boris
johnson will be prime minister tomorrow
morning that's what we've got to focus
on
i want to zoom zaharwee there saying
that is a convincing win for the prime
minister time to draw a line uh under
things whether or not that will be
possible of course is another question
and we're joined now by uh labour's uh
david lammy what's your take on the
result well this is staggering it's
appalling
he's done worse than thatcher did in
1990 worse than john major in 1995 worse
than theresa may in 2018 all of those
prime ministers went on in the end to
lose their job 40
of his parliamentary party against him
most of his backbenchers against him at
a time when people are facing rising
inflation cost of living he's got a
parliamentary inquiry he's got two
by-elections this is a disaster and he
should go look the labour party have
been saying this of course for many many
months a lot of the public uh
us expressing what we hear on the
doorstep from the public
now we're seeing that the conservative
party have lost confidence in this prime
minister and it's on that basis that
frankly he should resign
you're saying that his party has lost
confidence in the prime minister but he
did still win this phone the more
conservative mps say that they have got
confidence in the prime minister
just
i mean
just and let's remember
160 uh of those uh 211 are on what we
call the government payroll
so
they're being paid he's done badly badly
i've been i've been in politics now 22
years and he's done very very badly um
indeed but in the end
look this isn't a partisan thing it's
about we need a prime minister that
people can trust we need a prime
minister when people wake up in the
morning they know that they've got he's
got their concerns how are you going to
fix the economy what are you going to do
for schools how are you going to get
those waiting lists down and i'm afraid
this is a prime minister over and over
again venal
self-serving i'm afraid untruthful
untrustworthy
if you can't trust him on the basics how
are you going to trust him on fixing our
economy so that people can actually get
out of this crisis it's on that basis
that his own mps listening to the emails
listening to the letters listening to
what they're hearing on the doorstep
voted against him tonight well i guess
allies of the pm are saying tonight that
what this vote does is to try i mean
whether or not it's going to be
successful as another thing but to try
and draw a line under that issue so that
they can move on to focusing on exactly
the kind of things that you're talking
about look they're not going to be
successful in drawing a line
i suspect he's going to lose these
by-elections coming up um it's all
revealed now the war within the
conservative party and let's remember
that it's going to be very hard for
boris johnson to reconcile
these two sides of the conservative
party you've got these red wall mps who
are concerned
frankly about this boris johnson because
they're they're hearing on the doorstep
people raising the issues of
truthfulness and then you've got tories
in the traditional southern shires
remain tories who've always been
suspicious how's he going to reconcile
that going forward when you've had this
number break out against him he's not
going to be able to is the truth and
that damage is not just his party it
damages the country at a time when we
need someone really focused on the job
it's all going to be about the internal
maneuverings of the conservative party
he's not going to resign is he though
look i mean i've always felt that this
is uh
a prime minister that we've never seen
before because it's a sort of
shamelessness um there's a lack of
integrity um that i don't recognize when
i think of david cameron who walked away
after um he lost the referendum theresa
may
these are not politicians that i share
their view on the outlook but they had a
certain core integrity to them this
prime minister hasn't got like that and
that's why his his backbenchers have
voted against
today he would say that he has won this
vote the confidence vote yes uh the
rebellion was higher than they hoped and
he also of course convincingly won the
2019 general election
he has got a mandate so if it's like a
b-52 bomber that's lost its engine it's
still flying but it's heading in one
direction and that's down to the ground
that's where boris johnson is tonight
he's walking wounded so it's bleeding
all over westminster and sadly it's it's
the country who will suffer as a
consequence of the conservative party's
failure to act failure to get rid of a
prime minister that we all want to see
the back of so do you want to see the
back of him i just because you say that
obviously in your view it's the public
that will suffer but is this
could it be argued that this is actually
the best possible result for the labour
party look i just think this is beyond
the day-to-day party politics i have to
say okay um i i don't see the
conservative party easily finding um you
know a candidate that's going to have
the kind of charisma and appeal that
they need but that's not really the
issue the issue is he should have left
office a long time ago he's still in
office they propped him up they're in
real trouble and they put the country
into trouble as a consequence okay uh
david lammie thank you very much uh
indeed uh so that was uh the labour view
uh on tonight's vote we can get some
reaction now uh from a member of the
cabinet we can go live now
to central lobby and talk to simon hart
who is the secretary of state for wales
what's your reaction to the vote
um i think it was slightly better than
anticipated that's not to sound in any
way complacent
boris johnson has gone from getting 51
when he was elected as leader to 60
tonight that's a that's an interesting
uh movement if you like in the voting
numbers what i would say is of course
you know we have to respect the views of
148 colleagues who would have reached
that decision you know after great ag
agonizingly it's in some cases and of
course you know the next stage of all of
this is seeing if we can unite people
around the cause for which we were
causes for which we were elected uh back
in 2019 and if i you know i've been in
and around the party for quite a long
time and we are quite good at saying
okay we've had this but we've expressed
our view we've fulfilled our
responsibilities to our constituents as
we see fit but we now uh have the
responsibility of returning to you know
governing as fairly incompetent as we
can so i i would like to think that we
can now coalesce around uh the reasons
uh as i say courses for which we were
first elected hang on a minute i just
have to pull you up uh on the comparison
you're making between boris johnson's uh
victory in the leadership contest and
this confidence motion because you're
really comparing apples and pairs here
aren't you i mean it's very different uh
binary
among conservative mps and whether
you've got confidence in your own prime
minister and whether or not you slightly
prefer another candidate in a leadership
election i mean come on
i i've been accusing people of not doing
apples and apples comparisons all day so
i i would like to think i have been
consistent i'm trying to be as
consistent as possible all i'm saying is
that if we you know we vote on multiple
issues multiple times a day in this
building um the the rules of engagement
are very clear the person with the most
votes wins uh and whether that's one
vote or 20 votes hundred votes or
whatever that the party is and most
politicians to be fair are very much
respect and recognize that that's how
voting works we've now reached this
position a significant margin if i won
my own seat by the way with a margin of
this amount i'd be really really chuffed
a bit okay and nobody would be arguing
with the outcome i just wonder taking a
step back here you know
many mps seem to say that part of the
issue they had with the sue gray reports
and partygate was boris johnson's
reaction that he effectively didn't
really seem to be taking on board the
depth of people's feeling he wasn't
being humble enough he wasn't listening
and just hearing some of his allies
responding to this confidence vote by
saying actually he won decisively it was
great we can draw a line under it are
you just making the same mistake again
are you not listening
to what critics of the prime minister
are trying to tell you and could that
just make the situation worse
well i i hope that isn't uh an accurate
reflection of reality i've been in
in the chamber house of commons and
other places too when the pm has uh made
you know public references to what
happened and the and his role or
otherwise those responsibilities leader
and all of that and and i think you know
it was it is perfectly fair for people
to say that they expected contrition and
they expected evidence of uh some of the
sort of structural issues which led to
the problems in the first place to be
improved now okay as i say i'm i'm just
one voice in this i've heard those uh
remarks uh and they seem to me to be uh
entirely genuine there will be some you
know i think david okay
i'm gonna have to jump in and uh
apologies to uh simon hart because we
have just heard from the prime minister
let's hear uh what boris johnson has to
say
prime minister
hello good evening go on with 40 of your
mps against you so i think this is a
a very good result for for politics and
for
for the country justin it's just i i do
just in this sense i think it's a
convincing result a decisive result on
what it what it means
is that as uh
as a government we can move on and focus
on the stuff that i think really matters
to people i think it's a decisive
than you result your allies wanted her
to go straight away how how is this
different how can you possibly continue
this is a
i've got a far bigger mandate from my
own parliamentary colleagues for
instance than i had
in 2019 and
had a pretty good mandate
she had to go with it
i'm grateful to colleagues i'm grateful
for
the support they've given me and of
course i understand that what we need to
do now is come together
as a as a government as a party
and that is exactly what we can now do
and what this gives us is the
opportunity to put behind us all the
stuff that i know the uh the media have
quite properly wanted to focus on for a
very long time
and to do our job which is to focus on
uh the stuff that i think the public
actually want us to be talking about
which is what we are doing to help the
people of this country and all the
things we're doing to take this country
forward and so so what this means
tonight is that we can focus on exactly
that we can focus on what we're doing to
help people with the cost of living uh
with what we're doing to clear the code
with what we're doing to make uh streets
and communities safer by putting more
police out
and
it gives us the opportunity to continue
to unite to level up to strengthen our
economy we're going to go through a
continuing
difficult time because of the
inflationary pressures that the world is
experiencing but we have a lot of a lot
of natural strength not least the lowest
unemployment since 1974. and
what i think is important about tonight
and
you know forgive me i'm going to say it
again i think this is very good news
because it allows the government to
focus on uh on those issues and that's
what you say you want to focus on those
issues 148 mps on your own side are
against you they're going to be dragging
you through the mud how can you possibly
govern with it
you really think that's a good result
it's a good result i certainly think it
is because don't forget that uh you know
when i first stood to be
uh leader of the conservative party in
2019 i didn't get anything like uh that
much uh support from my my colleagues
involved uh were
doing that and uh what we have now is an
opportunity to put behind us all the
stuff as i say that uh
people in the media like going on about
and i think
the there's a difference in in the
category of conversation
i know you know people want to talk
about stuff that goes on at westminster
what i want to talk about is what we as
a government are doing so you need to
help all those entities and no what
we're going to do now is take the
opportunity
to unite and deliver and that is what we
want to do are you ruling out a snap
election is that not the only way
forward to stop you from being a lame
duck what we want to do
is to get on
use this moment which i think is
whatever you may say i think is is
decisive and conclusive and continue
with our priorities and and i think
those are
those are ruling out
we are going through a period when we
have to help people with the cost of
living and we are 1200 pounds for 8
million of the most vulnerable
households in the country plus a lot of
other support 500 400 pounds to
absolutely absolutely everybody with the
uh with the cost of energy the only
reason we can do that is because we have
a robust economy
unemployment the lowest level for for 50
years that is the
those are the things that really matter
to our country right now and uh yeah i'm
i am
pleased because we now have the chance
to talk exclusively
about those priorities and not about uh
all sorts of stuff that i know is of uh
obsessive and compulsive interest uh to
uh my beloved friends in the media but i
don't think really
matters as much
as the agenda of the government so
you're in a worse position than theresa
may was after her vote in 2018 and you
think this is a good result i think it's
an extremely good
positive conclusive decisive result
which enables us to move on uh to
unite
and to focus on delivery and that is
exactly what we're going to do and to
confirm you're ruling out a snapshot so
you keep asking about you know look this
is nice
i'm certainly i have no
i see no point in focusing on anything
else and i'm certainly not interested in
uh in snap elections what i'm interested
in is delivering right now for the
people of this country we've got an
amazing agenda we are we we have a
fantastic mandate uh a huge uh uh
biggest majority we secured in 2019 for
the conservatives for for 40 years uh i
if you look at what's happened just
happened in
impal whatever statistics you want to
chuck around i've got many more mps
supporting me now than i did in 2019 i'm
happy with that we're going to bash on
uh we have a huge agenda and we're going
to get it done so you still think you're
a popular prime minister in the party
and in the country
can i just say i think the most
important thing although you may want to
focus on me and on politics and on uh on
westminster i think what matters is what
we deliver and what we
do and as a result of this uh decision
tonight by the parliamentary party which
i welcome
we have a conclusion uh to something
that's been dragging on for far too long
and we have the ability now to unite
deliver and get on with the people's
priorities and that is what we're going
to do okay thank you thank you
boris johnson there giving his reaction
to that vote of confidence in his
leadership where 40
of his parliamentary party voted to say
they had no confidence in him as prime
minister he said i think this is a very
good positive inclusive decisive result
that allows us to move
on
let's talk now to our political
correspondent ali fortescue who is in
downing street for us and ali
was the journalist conducting at that
interview
ali what did you feel the tone of the
prime minister's response was
hi sophia i don't know about you but i
was quite struck by how buoyant the
prime minister seemed he um came in the
room almost sort of bouncing with energy
i thought and given um as you say that
we are talking about 148 mps from his
own party that this evening said they
had no confidence in him more than 40 of
his parliamentary party i was quite
struck by just how upbeat he sounded and
you heard me asking him there repeatedly
you know did he really think that this
was a good result yes he won the vote
but you know speaking to mps today i
don't think many people thought that he
was going to lose the question was just
how badly or just how well would he do
how would the numbers stack up and i
think this is a worse result
definitely than many people expected and
as i was saying in my interview this is
worse than theresa may she had a more
decisive victory and she was gone six
months later and at the time boris
johnson's allies were saying that she
was a lame duck saying that she couldn't
carry on so to see him i think buoyant
calling this a convincing victory saying
it had been a good night i thought was
quite striking i thought that perhaps he
might strike a more serious tone he said
this was the moment to unite to focus on
the domestic agenda but i think the
reality is with that many mps from his
own party against him that could now be
very challenging
yeah certainly the kind of the gulf
between the prime minister's tone and
that many of his mps are really quite
striking uh this evening ali foski thank
you very much uh indeed ali there in
downing street well let's get some more
reaction uh now shall we uh to that
result we're joined now by sonia soder
who's the chief leader writer at the
observer and sarah southern a former
aide to david cameron sarah let's get to
you first
a positive result a decisive about
results time to move on doesn't feel
like that um i think if you've got 41 of
your parliamentary party voting against
you you maybe aren't feeling as decisive
as as you would hope um i think the
comparison that the prime minister made
there he's done better than 2019 well
it's not a like-for-like election um if
that's the case maybe let's have a rerun
of the leadership election with the
party
uh yeah interesting uh take that and it
does feel like that comparison uh we've
heard simon hart doing it uh on this
program earlier boris johnson clearly
seems to perhaps be one of the lines to
take uh from number 10 in response to it
uh sonia soder do you think this is
worse than people expecting
it is worse than people are expecting
and it's kind of like it's a pretty bad
result for the conservative party as
well i think because at least if if the
rebels have got enough votes together to
sort of depose boris johnson imminently
that would have provided some kind of
decision for the conservative party here
you've almost got the worst of all
worlds really you've got a pretty
bad vote for the prime minister worse
than people were expecting that 2019
wrong i mean it's just like it's just
wrong actually um boris johnson got a
greater proportion of the parliamentary
party voting for him against uh jeremy
hunt back in 2019 than now so i think it
shows just quite how desperate they are
that they're sort of trying to find
these lines to spin and also it's a
different it's a completely different
thing it's a you know a confidence vote
in the prime minister compared to you
know a vote about who you would prefer
as a leader exactly and um so i think it
leads to prime minister really wounded i
think it massively undermines his
legitimacy and authority uh within his
parliamentary party we've got a couple
of really important by-elections coming
up in the next couple of weeks which it
actually looks like the conservatives
are going to lose both of them
so it's a pretty dire state of affairs
but you know boris johnson is boris
johnson he will try and cling on for as
long as he can but i think what this
means is we're going to be stuck with
the government that even more than ever
is just kind of afflicted by paralysis
strife conflict
and very little will get done for the
country the thing that really struck me
from boris johnson's interview there is
what it says about what he intends to do
in the coming months and it is pretty
clear that he is going to take this
result as as a mandate whether people
agree with it or not to dig in and to
he's certainly not going to resign is he
and what where do you think this leads
the conservative party going forward
well he really now needs to win those
mps back on side i don't believe he'll
resign
i appreciate that you know theresa may
lasted another six months after her
leadership
confidence vote
i think that the prime minister won't
resign but if he doesn't win those mps
back on side and if he doesn't win the
party membership back i can't see how
he's going to be in a strong position to
fight a general election
so let's see what the outcome of the
by-elections is at the end of june
we'll soon be into summer recess i think
the prime minister needs to decide
what his agenda is moving forward what
is it that he stands for how is he going
to tackle this cost of living crisis how
is he going to tackle the energy crisis
if he doesn't do a barnstorming speech a
party conference come october i think he
could be again in difficulty in terms of
having support from the the party
faithful and i think certainly you know
if any of the reaction to
for many conservative mps to this if he
makes it to the conference then that is
in some ways it's quite it's quite
hurdle to clear
um in some ways sonia do you think this
could be the best result for labour
you've got a prime minister who is
wounded despite the fact that his allies
are saying that he was decisive but it
doesn't look like he wants to go
anywhere i think for labour probably the
longer that boris johnson hangs around i
mean it's not great for the country but
i think probably the better for the
labour party because i think if you look
at the polling what you can see quite
clearly is that boris johnson is a real
drag on the conservative brand he's
doing much much worse than the party
itself i think the reason why he you
know this vote is so problematic for him
is it's reflective of the fact that his
mps have been out talking to their
constituents and we can see in the polls
that the public have really turned
against boris johnson in a way that they
just weren't quite there maybe six
months ago and
i think that's going to put a lot of
pressure on his mps and it would be
quite extraordinary if a prime minister
managed to turn around the level of
unpopularity that boris johnson now has
got with voters um i i think to turn
that around is is quite impossible
actually so i i i do think that sooner
or later his mps will out but i think
you know labor
it's a really good outcome for it for
labour you know that boris johnson sort
of hanging around um you know the tories
i mean some of the vitriol we've been
seeing from you know mps like nadine
doris against jeremy hunt on twitter and
social media today it's it's really
quite something uh it's been a long time
since we've seen a governing party
have this this level of public breakdown
so i i think it's going to make voters
even more cynical about johnson the
government talking about the voters um
and what you will hear allies of boris
johnson saying i guess is that look
pulls the polls an election if there's
no imminent election going on he was
taught talking to ali there saying that
he's got no desire to call a snap
election
and boris johnson is a proven election
winner he not only won the leadership
contest that they keep talking about but
he also won the 29 general election by a
landslide you know talking to mps like
alex stafford like i did earlier from
you know the valley the first ever
conservative mp for these kind of seats
they say why would you get rid of him
but that was boris johnson 2019 model so
much has happened so much has changed i
don't believe that the public have got
such an affection for him that they did
two and a half years ago you know what
was achieved in that 2019 election was
incredible i never thought in my
lifetime that i would see so many tory
seats in the northeast of england you
know i effectively come from tory
stronghold now but
i i think that that unless he brings
that pizzazz back i don't think the
public will be voting for him again
thank you both uh very much uh indeed
interesting to hear your thoughts
tonight well that is the end of our uh
general uh general election i was going
to say we talked about the general
elections
here we go
not for a while we're told
thank you very much for watching our
confidence motion uh program uh wow what
a result it was boris johnson winning
decisively according to the prime
minister he says that will allow him to
draw a line under things with 211 of his
own mps voting in favor if it's a
leadership but
148 conservative mps that is 4 in 10 of
the parliamentary party voting to say
that they do not have confidence in his
leadership it is going to be a rocky few
months ahead coming up next on sky news
at 10 denver monahan will have all the
latest reaction as the prime minister
survives tonight's confidence vote
[Music]
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from
understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
[Music]
so
[Music]
organism
[Music]
[Music]
it's 10 o'clock this is sky news at 10
live from downing street where the prime
minister is tonight wounded and gravely
weakened i can announce that the
parliamentary party does have confidence
[Applause]
applause but troubling signs for boris
johnson as a large group of his own mps
say they no longer have confidence in
the prime minister
there are calls tonight for the pm to
consider his position but his allies say
he has done enough to see off the
challenge to his authority
i think it's an extremely good
positive conclusive decisive result
which enables us to move on
to
unite
and to focus on delivery
mps
made their choice tonight
they have ignored the british public
and pitched themselves and their party
firmly to boris johnson and everything
that he represents
we'll have all the latest reaction from
a result that could redefine the future
of the conservative party and the
country
and we'll hear from voters in wakefield
in west yorkshire on what they make of
the turmoil in westminster
also tonight
hundreds more flights cancelled
thousands more travelers stranded and
tonight a warning that the travel chaos
at airports could last for weeks
ukraine's president leaves kiev to visit
a city on the front line and warns that
ukrainian resistance there is being
tested by heavy shelling
toasting an extra day off every week the
company's trying out a four-day plan to
improve productivity
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from half past ten
[Music]
good evening from downing street where
tonight boris johnson remains prime
minister but only after four in ten of
his own mps say they have lost
confidence in him the tory leader
survived a vote of confidence but the
result has dealt a severe blow to his
authority despite a last-ditch plea to
his mps concern over the partygate
scandal economic policy and mr johnson
himself saw 148 turn against him
allies say his victory should draw a
line under the issue but some
backbenchers tonight are calling on him
to stand down
coming up we'll hear from downing street
insiders and voters in west yorkshire
but our first report tonight comes from
our political editor beth rippy
the moment of truth for boris johnson
the vote in favour
uh of having confidence in boris
johnson's leader was 211 votes and the
vote against was 148 votes
and therefore i can announce that the
parliamentary party does have confidence
[Applause]
148 mps voting against their pm he wins
but this is hardly a victory the cheers
and banging of desks couldn't drown out
the reality over 40 percent of the party
just voted against its leader the pm
desperate to turn the page i think this
is a
a very good result for for politics and
for uh for the country justin it's just
i i do just in this sense i think it's a
convincing
result a decisive result on what it what
it means
is that as uh
as a government we can move on and focus
on the stuff that i think really matters
to people
but his detractors think the damage is
done unfortunately the issue can't be
settled like that
um a third over a third
of the parliamentary party has expressed
no confidence in the prime minister
a prime minister
of honour would look at the figures
accept the fact
that he has lost the
support of a significant proportion of
his party and consider his position the
labour leader happy to exploit divisions
in the ruling party
conservative mps
made their choice tonight
they have ignored the british public
and hitched themselves and their party
firmly to boris johnson and everything
that he represents
there had been an uneasy jubilee truce
between the pm and his party it was over
shortly after dawn as long-term johnson
ally jesse norman reignited the simran
rebellion with this letter calling the
pm's response to partygate grotesque and
calling on him to resign
confirmation quickly followed that
dozens of his colleagues agreed the
threshold of 15 of the parliamentary
party seeking a vote of confidence in
the prime minister has been passed
therefore a vote of confidence will take
place
the pm told on sunday the rebellion had
cleared its first hurdle with at least
54 of his own mps saying it was time for
him to go the cabinet dispatched to
insist he must stay i'm hoping we get
through this vote tonight and we can get
on and he's a he's a festival he's a
dead man walking thank you very much
he's a dead man he's a strong leader he
will get the get the big calls right and
thank you very much for all your time
but this rebellion had been building for
months bringing in all factions of the
tory party from all intakes please of
loyalists doing little to change the
minds of those out of patience like this
mp boris johnson's anti-corruption czar
resigning after concluding his boss
broke the ministerial code
is he done whichever way now
i i fear that that is probably the case
i think it's over and i fee it feels now
like a question of when not if you know
at the moment in so far as anyone can
tell
it feels like the beginning of the end
and facing such an acute leadership
crisis boris johnson nowhere to be seen
in public leaving the estonian pm alone
on the doorstep of number 10 as the
british pm hid inside his political woes
disrupting the duties of leadership and
then later behind these windows he made
one last plea to his party before the
voting began stick with me he said the
best is yet to come
the vote tonight shows how many of boris
johnson's mps disagree with him two and
a half years ago they cheered him on as
he won that 80-seat majority but tonight
148 of them have said it's time for him
to go from all powerful to deeply
damaged from untouchable to deeply
tarnished once adored now disdain this
vote is undoubtedly a mortal blow to his
political authority yes he survives but
can he ever recover the pm's allies like
to say never write off boris johnson but
history says tory leaders never shake
off the damage of a confidence vote
whatever the outcome for now he stays in
office but is he really now in power
beth rigby sky news westminster
well of course tonight's vote might have
seemed unthinkable two and a half years
ago when boris johnson's conservatives
won the general election with an 80-seat
majority but of course revelations about
partying in downing street during the
pandemic and the prime minister's
response to the internal investigation
soured the mood for some tory mps and
when that has happened in the past it
has ultimately proved fatal for other
conservative leaders now our deputy
political editor sam coach's report does
contain some flashing images
a conservative winner like no other in
four decades
always an unconventional path which took
him to the heart of the establishment
proving doubters wrong with an 80-seat
majority tory mps were told time and
again to trust him through the
turbulence holidays and wallpaper but
who paid for what upending the rules for
an mp found guilty of sleaze parties in
downing street and the denials that
followed
but dealing with brexit the pandemic the
cost of living crisis and war in ukraine
never allowed a moment for politics as
normal
[Music]
all the time gradually the public were
changing their mind
now tory mps have threatened him a life
ring a win yes but far from settling
manners has it just exposed divisions
veterans of past story leadership
challenges clear there's trouble ahead
what we have seen today is a classic
example of a party where its fractures
become very very open
between the members of parliament as
they're looking for their own particular
constituency so it's a big deal and it
can't be underestimated and boris
johnson is going to be damaged there's
no two ways about it
all this barely three years on from the
last attempt to ouster pm the
parliamentary party
does have confidence
[Applause]
theresa may survived on the day but was
gone within six months but with enormous
and enduring gratitude
to have had the opportunity
to serve the country i love
history suggests vote like today's
rarely settle matters
john major was never the same again and
mark thatcher fell on her sword uh and
theresa may uh was
uh faithfully wounded it's a vote in
time but uh but a lot of things happen
very quickly
for a
prime minister who has the skates under
them
this is the messiest of all outcomes for
boris johnson cabinet ministers in
public saying a win is a win but in
private insiders quite open that the
poor showing tonight is going to make
their life more difficult
and now what if the tories lose both
by-elections in a few weeks time or if
mps judged that boris johnson lied to
the commons
right now the conservative party seems
on balance determined to place its faith
in a man who delivered their landslide
barely three years ago
sam coates sky news westminster
well boris johnson may have survived
tonight's vote but he has other
challenges on the horizon the first of
those will come in a bit over a
fortnight when voters in two
conservative seats go to the polls one
of those by-elections will be in
wakefield in west yorkshire and our
people and politics correspondent nick
martin has been speaking to voters there
about how events in westminster today
might influence their vote
in the next few weeks this cathedral
city in west yorkshire will vote for a
new mp
and the result could tell us a lot about
how people feel about the prime minister
and his government
cities like wakefield which will labor
for so long turned tori in the last
general election and that helped to
secure victory for boris johnson but now
a recent poll suggests that labour are
20 points ahead here and if that's true
then the conservatives could be heading
for a crushing defeat in this
by-election
it's been a bruising time for boris
johnson and the lockdown parties and
subsequent fines seem to hit a nerve
with some voters the things that he's
done put us in lockdown then have his
own party
he's just gone against his own word so
it's disgusting really why was he
ignoring the restrictions why was he
ignoring the rules is it the partying
that's really
got you upset it's not helped his case
does it it's not helped it no
if it came to a general election a vote
now
would you be happy for him to continue
as a prime minister
i've got no option
you've got no option no option
the tory win here in 2019 was remarkable
labor after all had held this seat since
the 1930s
[Applause]
the question is whether after everything
that's happened have they got enough
support to win again it just comes
across as a
bumbling a bit idiotic at times and
end the day he's going to living down
his sword and he made the rules and he's
decided to break him
so for you you had faith in him you had
faith him in at the beginning you were
willing to vote for him but it's the
party thing is it that's that's dented
that faith
i would definitely say the party that if
he can't keep his own rules he can't be
trusted and trust is the main thing that
you need as these kids growing up you
want the best for their for their future
and given that you know how he's led
over the past few years it's not been
great
support for politicians can flourish and
wither in the blink of an eye annetta
ford is a florist in the city and she's
also a loyal conservative
what he's done since brexit
covet
and ukrainian war
um
that is that is the main thing so i'm
looking on the bigger picture not just a
glass of wine and i've i got that
confidence i have to say
yeah
so you believe that
going forward he should remain prime
minister because he's getting more right
than wrong
well yeah in a nutshell yeah
a defeat in wakefield would pile even
more pressure on the prime minister at a
time when confidence in his leadership
is being tested to the limits nick
martin sky news wakefield
well let's bring beth rigby back in and
beth 148 of his own mps voting against
him i mean that's clearly a bad night
the question i suppose is just how bad
well dumb i think the first thing to say
is that this result is worse than his
allies had hoped for that is very clear
148 mps voting against him they didn't
want any sort of figure like that so
that's the first thing to say the second
thing to say is he survived it now under
tory party rules that means he should be
safe for a year unless things
dramatically deteriorate and mps ask
graham brady to look at it again so
that's a second thing to say but the
third thing to say about it is when 148
of your own mps say they don't have
confidence in you how are you going to
run your programme of government because
if you have 40 mps that consistently
rebel that are galvanized by this vote
that decide that they've lost confidence
in you and they are not coming back to
the table
the prime minister's not really going to
be able to get any legislation through
and if he thinks tonight he's drawn a
line under it as he was saying to ali
fortescue impala in number 10 i've just
had this through from a very senior
conservative saying it's time for the
cabinet to show some leadership and
realize the game's up for the prime
minister so that is not drawing a line
under anything at all look dermot what's
going on here there was a simmering
civil war going on for months really
this has been blown open now by this
confidence vote yes he survived it but
you can't put the genie back in the
bottle the damage has been done and now
the question is whether and how much he
struggles on in the coming months okay
beth manny
beth rigby our political editor there
without analysis and the result of
tonight's vote is all over tomorrow's
papers it goes without saying here's the
financial times summing it up with the
headline
johnson wounded in confidence voters 41
of tory mps rebel
and you can scroll through the front
pages while watching our extended press
preview and news review by scanning the
qr code on your screen right now joining
us in downey street from half past 10
this evening will be the daily mirrors
political editor pippa carrera and the
times home affairs editor matt dathan
harpaste
well on to other news now and thousands
of people are stuck abroad tonight after
hundreds of flights were cancelled at
the end of the bank holiday weekend many
of them are stranded in airports while
others are trying to make other
arrangements to try to get home
well more than 140 more flights were
cancelled today easyjet british airways
and tui all canceled flights many at
short notice including over a hundred
short-haul ba departures from heathrow
over the bank holiday weekend 189
flights into the uk were scrapped and on
top of that over 300 flights leaving for
international locations were also
cancelled
over 15 000 people have been affected
either without a flight delayed or stuck
with nowhere to go as becky johnson now
reports
annie massey should be on a school trip
abroad by now
her stepmother naomi due back at the
primary school and crew where she
teaches
instead their family holiday in portugal
ended with a night in faro airport when
their easyjet flight was
desperate to get back they flew to paris
on sunday only to find their train was
cancelled too already 2 000 pounds out
of pocket they're still not home
um
so angry really easyjet for one because
there's been absolutely no communication
with them whatsoever i still now
you know
36 hours nearly later i can't get onto
the app i still can't work out an
alternative flight
easyjet have apologized to customers but
they're not the only airline canceling
flights passengers at luton were left
disappointed it makes us think twice
about traveling abroad again really does
just
because you need such you need nerves of
steel and a huge amount of energy and to
be very flexible in your thinking the
problem is staff shortages airports and
airlines unable to recruit and get
security clearance for staff quickly
enough since travel restrictions were
lifted
this is stretching everyone to the limit
and i don't see this getting any better
over the next few weeks because there
simply aren't enough people working
within the aviation environment to solve
this
bad news for the many thousands stuck
abroad
passengers whose flights are landing
back in the uk will be counting
themselves among the lucky ones for all
those left stranded the main questions
now are when they'll be able to get home
and when or if they'll get any of their
money back the transport secretary has
said passengers should get automatic
compensation but aviation bosses blame
the government for not doing enough to
help end the chaos becky johnson sky
news
the battle for eastern ukraine is
becoming increasingly intense the
ukrainian president said today that the
fierce bombardment of these
strategically important cities of severo
donetsk and lissa chance have left them
in his words dead well despite that
russian forces have been pushed back
marginally and last night vladimir
zelinski visited the front line
russian and ukrainian troops are now
fighting street by street in severo
donetsk a crucial battle which could be
the key to the dondas
just days ago russia controlled 70
percent of the city but the recent
fighting has seen their troop
troops pushed back away from the twin
city of lissa chansk aleister bunkel
reports now from dunipro west of donbass
this by president zalenski was
extraordinary he isn't in a secure
bunker safely away from the action he is
right on the front line next to some of
the fiercest fighting of this conflict
in the town of lucifer
just think what message these pictures
send to the soldiers and the ukrainian
people
just think what message it sends to the
kremlin
can you imagine vladimir putin taking
this kind of risk
each family has its own story most were
without men someone's husband went to
war someone's in captivity someone's
unfortunately died a tragedy no home no
loved one but we must live for the
children true heroes they are among us
this is what it looks like above ground
the shelling is relentless as both sides
dig in and fight for small gains
but the battle could be pivotal and so
that's why zelinski put himself right in
the middle of it to g up his troops and
why russia is throwing everything at it
they put too much
forces there they put too much effort
and we still have a difference in
numbers of and in capabilities that is
why we saw like a weight in
uh all the military systems which we
should gain with the better artillery
better air defense and
which provide us a better capability to
hold on and to then to make a counter
offensive
those weapons are now on their way the
americans and british are providing them
and they are expected to be here soon
the russians aren't happy
yesterday
if all of this on the part of the united
states and its satellites is a reaction
to what is happening then i will
emphasize again
the longer the range system supplied to
the kiev regime will have the farther we
will push the nazis from the line from
where they could threaten the russians
in ukraine and the russian federation
both sides are fighting this war at huge
cost the death toll is enormous
the faces of the dead ukrainian soldiers
line a long wall in the centre of kiev
now
civilian deaths too cemeteries are now
filling with freshly dug graves it is no
exaggeration to say that some burial
grounds are simply running out of room
the sacrifice being made in defense of
this country could at times leave you
speechless
as debunked sky news in eastern ukraine
i've heard the 77 cases of monkey pox
have been detected in the united kingdom
it brings the total number of confirmed
cases in the country to 302 the health
security agency said 287 of those cases
are in england 10 in scotland 3 in wales
and 2 in northern ireland
the police watchdog is appealing for
witnesses after a man died entering the
river thames after being tasered by
officers police were called to chelsea
bridge road in west london on saturday
morning following reports of a man armed
with a screwdriver and shouting he was
rescued by the rnli but later died in
hospital
elon musk is threatening to cancel his
deal to buy twitter alleging that the
company has failed to disclose the
number of fake accounts on the platform
the billionaire who's spearheading the
44 billion dollar takeover has made a
number of comments in recent weeks
criticizing twitter and its management
team
well returning to the conservative
leadership vote and whatever the
political battles here in westminster
for most people it's the cost of living
crisis that will affect them the most
it's being harshly felt in places like
gooseberry in west yorkshire where one
local food bank has seen donations drier
our community's correspondent lisa
holland has this report
you know things are getting bad in this
cost of living crisis when a food bank
has to turn away hungry people
a week ago this was empty it was
completely empty so we had a table that
had very few items on and we had very
little tin food left the cupboard was
bare it was
after an urgent online appeal volunteers
at this food bank in dewsbury in west
yorkshire were able to restock
um
you get four times in there
but they're lurching from one week to
the next
we run out of food we we absolutely ran
out of food at this wood bank um and i
was shocked in some ways but in another
no this is something that i i
should have expected because
our
list has become so overwhelmed
um and people are reaching out so much
more
i made the last donation about a couple
of months ago
approximately
youtube we can't afford it you know
simple as
this is at the heart of why some food
banks are worried even the donors are
falling on hard times
ziggy has run a corner shop for more
than 40 years
so you've stopped stocking
the most expensive wines basically it's
money stuck up on the shelves which
needs to be turned over so the expensive
wines you stop saying you stop selling
nobody's got any money including the
shopkeeper whose energy bills to power
the fridges are 500 pounds a week
but it hurts he's no longer able to give
back to the community
we should run a lot of grocery
a lot of pop bottles
and bits crisp and stuff like that
we feel horrible because we cannot
donate the stuff that we like to donate
again
which you can't afford to do
but when help dries up we found a darker
side to the desperation
business after business told us petty
crime has gone through the roof
usually they just come grab something
it's very cheap as well for three pound
two pound they grab and they just walk
away with it
this delivery driver says he can't leave
boxes of stock unattended for even a
minute
i have to take one out
close the doors
and each time i take it out one shut the
doors because it's not safe yeah no safe
well you think someone's gonna steal it
yes
things are that bad yes
yeah it's very bad now
is that the cost of living crisis
yeah 100
people say they can't remember it like
this
in shops customers arguing over prices
and profit margins that are tiny
for example them hair removal things
they that probably not even cost
probably not even a two penny or three
vanilla that's your profit yeah
and that's because you just think no
one's going to buy it yeah because if i
put that 130 people still complain he's
saying why is it going up
no wonder people are afraid of the
future when even the hand that feeds
them is struggling lisa holland sky news
jews brie
well now before the pandemic working
from home was something of a rarity well
now bosses are under pressure to keep
changing the way we work today that came
in the shape of a scheme to give some
workers a four day working week and
while that might sound like a recipe for
relaxing it's actually intended to
improve productivity our business
correspondent paul kelso explains
a cold beer is one reward for a hard
week's work this north london brewer
wants to bring that well-earned drink
forward introducing a four day week for
staff who receive the same wages as for
five and be expected to be just as
productive
we have to be more efficient and think
about different ways potentially of
doing things like today i'm packaging
the kegs ahead of a canning run so
instead of packaging them all on the
same day we're kind of splitting those
tasks up a little bit that means we'll
finish canning it sooner which means
we'll be able to clean it sooner which
means we're sort of like trying to get
ahead
going through the pandemic and lockdown
and working from home it really gave i
think a lot of us pulls for how we work
how we structure our work we're a really
small close-knit team here which i also
think goes towards
feeling like you're kind of supported
and that you will be able to yeah
efficiently get your time into those
like four days
the boss hopes a better quality of life
will help him attract staff and improve
productivity
this is something we feel we can do
where we may not be able to offer our
staff the pay rises that they want this
year
but we can offer something that improve
their lives in a different way
this is one of more than 70 companies
taking part in what is the largest ever
trial of the four day week and it comes
after two years in which covid changed
the way many people work and their
expectations of their job and with the
economy facing a downturn it may be the
perfect time to discover whether british
workers really can be more productive
the uk is amongst the worst for our long
hours working culture we're normally the
top or second to the top for the longest
hours worked in europe and yet our
productivity lags we find behind
countries such as germany the
netherlands even france
millions have just enjoyed the benefits
of a long weekend courtesy of the
jubilee but some worn a permanent
extension may not suit all jobs
i think we're not there yet it might be
5 10 20 years away
the reason i don't think it'll work now
is the timing is so bad you know we've
just come out of covert we're just
coming out of brexit and the economy may
be going into recession and i think if
we suddenly whack it with a basically a
25 pay increase it could just destroy
the economy
the trial will last six months after
which more people may be toasting a
shorter week for the same pay
paul kelso sky news
and that was sky news at 10 coming up
we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
papers in the press preview
including this story on the front of the
daily star their headline carry on
pinocchio
tonight we're joined by the daily
mirrors political editor
crera and the times home affairs editor
matt dathon
[Music]
[Music]
you